das Saarland Welt die erste von vier
Landtagswahlen in diesem Jahr und die
erste nach dem Regierungswechsel im Bund
schon deshalb ist diese Wahl von
Interesse denn auch hier bahnt sich
tatsächlich ein Machtwechsel an Matthias
vorne ja die bestehenden
Kräfteverhältnisse in der großen
Koalition die könnten sich komplett
drehen in unserer letzten Umfrage diese
Woche jedenfalls lag die SPD sehr
deutlich vor der bisher stärksten Partei
der CDU für die SPD könnte diese Wahl
viele Optionen bringen weiter so in der
groko jetzt aber im Chefsessel oder
Rot-Grün oder rot-gelb vorausgesetzt
Grüne und FDP schaffen es überhaupt in
den Landtag und damit sind wir beim
vielleicht spannendsten Thema dieser
Wahl welche der vier kleineren Parteien
schaffts über die fünf Prozent Hürde für
die Linke wird es auf jeden Fall schwer
wenn sie nicht in den Landtag kommt
könnte es sogar reichen für eine
absolute Mehrheit der SPD jede Stimme
also zählt
so engen Verhältnissen erst recht ja
enge Verhältnisse Antworten auf all die
Fragen gibt es darauf im Laufe des
Abends an dem wir über den Wahlausgang
hier im Saarland berichten aber den
Blick natürlich auch in die Ukraine
richten in einem zdf-spezial so gegen 18
Uhr 20 die Uhrzeit 18 Uhr kennen sie
dann gibt es pünktlich die Prognose der
Forschungsgruppe Wahlen und bis dahin
können wir uns die Ausgangslage hier im
Saarland genauer anschauen Matthias
Kubitza hat den Überblick
wie groß ist eigentlich das Saarland die
Fläche Deutschlands geteilt durch 139
ja dieses Bundesland ist kleiner als so
mancher Landkreis
wahre Größe misst man deshalb hier nicht
in Quadratkilometern sondern in Kultur
Geschichte und Superlativen in keinem
anderen Bundesland zum Beispiel ist der
Anteil an Laubwald so hoch wie hier oder
der der Eigenheimbesitzer und auch der
der Katholiken
[Musik]
Leid und Krieg mitten in Europa liegen
als Schatten auch hier über der sonst
schon fast französischen Gelassenheit
im Moment ist sowieso alles furchtbar
schwierig die ganze Situation
Zustand der Angst schon von 100,00
wie schnell wird der Saarstahl grün
wird fort E-Autos im Werk Saarlouis
bauen oder im spanischen Valencia
wie soft oder Harz wird der Wandel im
Saarland also weitergehen
die Arbeitsplätze hier sind nicht so
gesichert wie man immer meint momentan
haben wir halt die Problematik dass die
die Ford in Saarlouis am Schwimmen ist
ne Stahlindustrie in Dillingen sieht
momentan auch nicht so rosig aus was
erwarten die Menschen im Saarland
außerdem von der Politik was muss besser
werden
[Musik]
den Lehrermangel bekämpfen ganz extrem
ich bin ja Fahrradfahrer was mir mich
betrifft muss da viel mehr getan werden
für die infrastrukturstände die überall
sind und wo was leer steht kommen dann
die billigschäden drin das Saarland hat
die Wahl und Deutschland schaut hin auf
dieses ganz besondere
139 der Republik
ja und das waren die Themen die die
Wählerinnen und Wähler hier beschäftigen
unsere ZDF Studioleiterin im Saarland
ist Susanne Freitag die dem Wahlkampf
natürlich jetzt intensiv beobachtet hat
Susanne das war ja kein ganz normaler
Wahlkampf er war unter anderem von dem
Thema Corona sehr bestimmt ja vor allem
man konnte halt nicht
Wahlveranstaltungen machen wie man das
sonst macht in großen Hallen mit vielen
Leuten man musste rausgehen auf die
Märkte das haben die Parteien auch zum
größten Teil gemacht und dann hat er die
ganze Kurbel Pandemie natürlich auch die
Themen bestimmt die Industrie hier war
massiv davon betroffen das haben viele
Parteien auch aufgenommen und beide
Kandidaten der großen Parteien waren
covid positiv das heißt Anke Redinger
war zum Teil auf
Wahlkampfveranstaltungen als
pappkandidatin und Tobias Hans fuhr mit
dem Roboter Robi Tobi durch die
Fußgängerzone das hat ihn zwar nahbarer
gemacht ob das was gebracht hat das wird
sich jetzt noch zeigen aber für die
kleinen Parteien war das natürlich auch
schwierig weil die sehr unbekannt sind
sehr klein und das hat es für sie nicht
leichter gemacht sich bekannt zu machen
das Duell an der Spitze darum geht es
natürlich war denn hier nach zehn Jahren
großer Koalition unter CDU-Führung so
was zu spüren wie eine Wechselstimmung
ja das schon vor allen Dingen als man
die ersten Umfragen gesehen hat es war
vor allen Dingen auch eine
Wechselstimmung nach über 20 Jahren CDU
geführter Regierung da hat man schon
gesagt hier kann jetzt mal ein Wechsel
passieren das hat man auch bei den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern wahrgenommen
aber so richtig viel Wechsel wird wohl
nicht gewünscht also man kann sich
vorstellen dass vielleicht die Spitze
sich mal ändert und die SPD nach vorne
tritt aber man wünscht sich doch
überwiegend eine große Koalition und die
SPD da hat man sehr deutlich gemerkt
dass sie diesen Wechsel vorantreiben
will hier waren unheimlich viele
Bundespolitiker die den Wahlkampf
unterstützt haben bei der CDU war das
gar nicht so da war wirklich niemand
mehr da in den letzten drei Wochen
Tobias hans war ganz alleine obwohl er
eigentlich gar nicht so schlechte Werte
hat für die CDU im Vergleich zu SPD
natürlich schon danke für die Eindrücke
erstmal aus dem Wahlkampf danke Susanne
bis später ja weiter mit der großen
Koalition vielleicht nur unter
SPD-Führung dann das ist so Szenario auf
der sich Anke Rehlinger aber keinesfalls
festgelegt hat und je nachdem wie die
kleinen Parteien abschneiden könnte
können sich für die SPD natürlich auch
noch andere Optionen ergeben Mathias wie
wird das von den Wählern gesehen was
sagen da die vorumfragen welche
Bündnisse wünschen die sich ja die große
Koalition ist tatsächlich die
beliebteste hier im Saarland jedenfalls
wenn die SPD sie führt das sehen wir
hier 54 Prozent sagen dass dagegen wird
Rot-Grün und wird auch rot gelb deutlich
abgelehnt die kleinen Parteien werden
hier generell eher kritisch gesehen auch
Grüne und FDP die ja zuletzt nicht im
Landtag vertreten waren die
saarländischen grünen das sehen wir hier
im Land mit deutlich negativer Bewertung
etwas besser im Bund und ähnlich sieht
es bei der FDP aus die Landespartei
deutlich schwächer als die im Bund
danke schön Matthias ja dann schauen wir
jetzt zu den einzelnen Parteien wo
unsere Reporterinnen und Reporter heute
abend Erfolg oder Niederlage beobachten
und wir beginnen bei den kleinen
Parteien die allesamt um den Einzug
insa-parlament bangen müssen und noch
etwas gemeinsam haben Grüne FDP AFD und
Linke alle hatten oder haben noch immer
mit inneren Querelen zu kämpfen bei den
Grünen die Ferien führten Grabenkämpfe
ja letztes Jahr sogar dazu dass die
Partei an der Saar nicht mal eine
gültige Landesliste für die
Bundestagswahl Zustande bekam nun wird
Harmonie beschworen Eve und die Hoffnung
ist wieder in den Landtag zu schaffen
absolut Bettina ja die Grünen Wahlparty
findet hier in der welletage über dem
Spielcasino statt und hier hofft die
Partei das möglichst viele heute
natürlich auf Grün setzen denn klar ist
die Partei will zurück in den Landtag
und am liebsten auch mitregieren doch
wie du gesagt hast durch die
Grabenkämpfe wurde viel Vertrauen
verspielt aber nach dem Bundestagswahl
Desaster hat man nun wieder auf
Neubeginn gesetzt man setzt auf
Teamgeist auf frischen Wind vor allem
mit der jungen Spitzenkandidatin dieser
Becker ob es klappt wird man gleich
sehen um 18 Uhr wenn es in den
Wahllokalen heißt um mal hier im
Spielcasino Jargon zu bleiben rähne war
plu nichts geht mehr
Dankeschön Eve die Grünen sind
Regierungspartei im Bund genauso wie die
FDP die sich nun auch Schwung erhofft
aus Berlin denn hier an der Saar sind
die Liberalen ebenfalls nicht im Landtag
vertreten kassenrüger das soll sich
ändern aber die umfragen sagen auch hier
eine wackelpartie an der 5% Hürde voraus
ist die Stimmung
ja Bettina die Liberalen feiern hier in
einer Großraumdisco ego-club ist der
Name heute früher war es sehr Gloria
Palast ob es einen glorreiches Ergebnis
für die Liberalen heute geben wird ob es
eine ruhmreiche Rückkehr ins Parlament
geben wird und ob diese
Champagnerflaschen geköpft werden das
ist wirklich völlig offen und groß ist
das Zittern man muss sich vor Augen
halten die Liberalen vor zehn Jahren
sind sie in der Bedeutungslosigkeit
versunken 1,2 Prozent hier an der Saar
vor fünf Jahren bei der Landtagswahl nur
3,3%. die Spitzenkandidatin Angelika
peter versucht also über die fünf
Prozent Hürde zu kommen gibt als Ziel
sogar acht Prozent aus sehr optimistisch
aber die meisten mit denen ich mich hier
unterhalten habe sagen wenn wir
wenigstens drin sind dann haben wir was
zu feiern
ja danke Carsten für diese Eindrücke und
weiter zur AFD die Chancen hat nach den
Formfragen hier heute die 5 Prozent
würde zu nehmen obwohl man ja eigentlich
das Ergebnis vom letzten Mal gut sechs
Prozent deutlich steigern wollte danach
sieht es Ralf stepanski ganz und gar
nicht aus nicht mal einen
Spitzenkandidaten gibt es
AFD man Alexander gauland hatte mal von
seiner Partei gesagt dass seien gäriger
Haufen und mit Blick hier auf die Saar
AFD kann man getrost sagen hier brodelt
es besonders bitter alle Männer an der
Spitze und es gibt nur Männer an der
Spitze sind heillos zerstritten die
landeswahlliste heimlich zurückgezogen
der Spitzenkandidat kalt gestellt ein
Parteiausschlussverfahren man kann sagen
es gibt das volle Programm und so gibt
es hier in der Landesgeschäftsstelle
zwar jetzt heute hier eine Party aber ob
so richtig Stimmung hier aufkommen will
in diesem Flachbau in einem Hinterhof am
Rande der Stadt das kann man getrost
zumindest bezweifeln denn allzu gut
stehen die Chancen nicht wirklich sich
zu steigern man gibt das Ziel aus acht
Prozent das so heißt es hier hieße man
sei mit einem blauen Auge davon gekommen
aber in einer Viertelstunde wissen wir
mehr
ja danke schön Ralf und schließlich dann
noch die Linke dass sie im Saarland mal
zu den kleinen gezählt werden könnte
konnte sich vor wenigen Jahren noch
niemand vorstellen die Galionsfigur
Oskar Lafontaine auch
ex-spd-ministerpräsident führte die
Linke 2009 zu über 20 Prozent nun ist
lafonte hinweg im Streit gegangen die
Partei im Grabenkampf und die Umfragen
sehen die Linke unter der 5% Hürde
Linder Kirsten da droht ein bitterer
Abend
ja es könnte besser laufen für die Linke
hier im Saarland vor fünf Jahren da war
die Pattaya mit mehr als 12 Prozent in
den Landtag eingezogen damals als
allerdings auch noch Zug fährt Oskar
Lafontaine am Steuer und der ist ja
bekanntermaßen vor anderthalb Wochen
sogar aus der Partei ausgetreten in den
Umfragen da stand die Linke zuletzt bei
5 und dann sogar nur noch bei 4%, und
das liegt auch daran dass es hier viele
parteiinterne Streitereien gegeben hat
und als i-Tüpfelchen sozusagen gilt das
schlechte Ergebnis bei der
Bundestagswahl es liegt ein schwerer
Wahlkampf hinter der Partei und
Spitzenkandidatin Barbara Spaniol sie
darf sich zuletzt zwar kämpferisch das
dürfte allerdings nichts daran ändern
dass die Partei hier heute Abend
wirklich zittern muss
vielen Dank sie werden das für uns
beobachten Dankeschön und wie immer in
der Wahlsendung dabei ist natürlich
Professor Karl Rudolf kortisch schön
guten Abend so wir bleiben vielleicht
noch mal ein Moment bei der Linken und
bei Oskar Lafontaine hat der diesem Land
ja wirklich über Jahrzehnte sein Stempel
aufgedrückt hat und jetzt wir haben es
gehört kurz vor dem Wahltermin ja im
Streit die Brocken hingeworfen hat das
ist jetzt irgendwie dann auch eine
Geschichte des Scheiterns oder ja er war
immer ein großer mobilisierer ein
leidenschaftlicher großherur der für die
SPD und für die Linken ganz viel
gerissen hat aber wenn er aufhört
hinterlässt er immer verbrannte Erde und
so sieht es ja heute hier auch aus nun
ist heute die erste Landtagswahl nach
der Bundestagswahl ein halbes Jahr neue
Vorzeichen im Bund dort regiert die
Ampel SPD regiert wie weit werden sich
diese Verhältnisse hier widerspiegeln
der Parteienwettbewerb ist
unvergleichbar zur
zurückliegenden Bundestagswahl wir
blicken in einen kriegsabgrund insofern
sind die Koordinaten der deutschen
Politik vollkommen anders es ist eher
interessant nach Kiel und Düsseldorf zu
gucken wie sich also die
Weiterentwicklung an die Gewöhnung des
angstszenarios um den Krieg und mit dem
Krieg sich entwickelt aber die
Vergleichbarkeit mit der Ampel und dem
parteienbewerb der Bundestagswahl die
ist nur sehr schwer Hersteller wir haben
einfach ein Epochenbruch
gleichwohl hat Olaf Scholz schon
angekündigt im letzten Herbst es solle
jetzt doch ein sozialdemokratisches
Jahrzehnt beginnen wir müssen mal sehen
ob sich das dann heute hier auch
niederschlägt vielen Dank für den Moment
Professor Korte haben wir einiges zu
bereden später und wir schauen jetzt mal
auf das Duell an der Spitze vier Jahre
ist CDU-Ministerpräsident Tobias Hans im
Amt der Wahl aber stellt er sicher zum
ersten Mal für Anke Rehlinger seine
Herausfordererin von der SPD ist es der
zweite Anlauf und für sie stehen die
Zeichen jetzt auf sie die Parteien zeigt
uns Matthias Kubitza
das rote und das schwarze Telefon die
Saarländer klingeln bei ihren Kandidaten
durch die Anke und der Tobias wollten
das im Wahlkampf so kein Scherz
rehlingers Handy könnte ein paar mal
mehr geklingelt haben
sie wird gewinnen die Frau Rehlinger und
das Hänschen muss dann in der Rente
gehen ich glaube grundsätzlich dass die
SPD Moment bessere Chancen hat ich wäre
für eine Hans die heiße Wahlkampfphase
aus der coronaisolation
gewollt bürgernah aber auch kritisiert
für seine inszenierte Spritpreis Wut an
der Tanke für Tobias Hans von der CDU
hätte der Wahlkampf besser laufen können
als jüngster Landesvater gab er sich
modern und voller Ideen doch der Funke
sprang nicht über es fehlte auch
Rückenwind aus Berlin und seine
Konkurrentin ist stark ich kämpfe nicht
mit einem Plan B sondern ich kämpfe
dafür vorne zu liegen das ist das Ziel
und dafür habe ich mich klar geäußert im
Gegensatz zur SPD die die ampelregierung
offen lässt die SPD deutlich vor der CDU
vor allem ihretwegen
Wirtschaftsministerin Anke Rehlinger
gibt sich als anpackerin pflegt ihr
Image als herzliches Saarländerin die
auf Chefin
in der entscheidendsten Frage für die
Zukunft dieses Landes nämlich
Arbeitsplätze zu schaffen habe ich
einiges schon auf den Weg gebracht die
Linke zerstritten erstmals ohne
Lafontaine und vielleicht unter fünf
Prozent ja wollen auch ein Korrektiv
nach wie vor bleiben in der
saarländischen Landespolitik ich glaube
das ist dringend notwendig auch die AFD
zerstritten bleibt wohl knapp im Landtag
die Probleme im Land sind so groß und
dann interessiert die Leute der Streit
in der Partei wer mit wem nicht kann das
ist muss zweitrangig sein knapp wird es
für die Grünen und die FDP beide hoffen
dass sie es zurück in den Landtag
schaffen und die durlanden werden jetzt
kurz vor der 18 Uhr Prognose bestimmt
auf ihre Handys schauen weil ihre
Anhänger da sicher gute Wünsche schicken
ja gut fünf Minuten sind es noch das
Rennen an der Spitze bevor wir gleich
auf die repräsentativen Ergebnisse
schauen wen die Wählerinnen und Wähler
sich eher wünschen würden erstmal die
Umfrage per menschlichem
Zufallsgenerator Carsten Behrendt ist
unser Wähler Reporter und hat Stimmen
eingefangen zur Frage wen will das
Saarland an der Spitze
wir sind hier direkt am Ufer der Saar
hier wird gegrillt und gechillt und bei
mir ist dass ihr paar Krämer lassen Sie
uns über die Spitzenkandidaten reden von
SPD und CDU warum kommt offensichtlich
Frau Rehlinger von der SPD besser an als
der amtierende Ministerpräsident Tobias
Hans sie tritt sie wollten souverän auf
sie ist selbstbewusst und sie hat
Erfahrung in bei der Regierung ich denke
im Moment sind wir bei ihr gut
aufgehoben Herr Krämer was denken sie ja
die corona-politik von der
johannissekunde mich also nicht
überzeugen dass ständige Hin und Her und
auch die letzten Auftritte die er hatte
fand ich nicht so angebracht und deshalb
finde ich Frau Rüdiger im Moment für uns
besser okay Frau Brockhaus sie stehen
neben den beiden sind Optikerin hier
welches Thema sollte der künftige
Landesvater die Landesmutter unbedingt
anpacken also wichtig ist die
wirtschaftliche Situation zu stärken die
Arbeitsplätze zu schaffen und zu
festigen und mir ist auch wichtig dass
die Kinder noch mal ein bisschen länger
Zeit haben zum Lernen
was G9 betrifft und das hat die SPD ja
schon etwas länger im Blick als die CDU
okay wir hören hier sind die Sympathien
relativ klar verteilt bei drei von
700.000 Wahlberechtigten hier im
Saarland und damit zurück ins
zdf-wahlstudio ja vielen Dank an Carsten
Behrendt jetzt schauen wir uns das mal
in der formfrage der Forschungsgruppe
Wahlen an Matthias und da fällt ja
tatsächlich eins auf dass wir hier einen
Amtsinhaber haben Tobias Hans der im
Grunde ohne Amtsbonus ist tatsächlich
eher ungewöhnlich die Herausfordererin
langjährige vize-regierungschefin und
Wirtschaftsministerin liegt klar vor und
das sehen wir hier weiter so mit Tobias
Hans sagen 31 Prozent eine Mehrheit von
57% will den Wechsel hin zu Anke
Rehlinger ganz anders als vor fünf
Jahren halten die Wählerinnen und Wähler
jetzt das Saarland für schlecht
vorbereitet auf die Zukunft und wer kann
das Saarland voranbringen Tobias Hans
das Sagen 17 Prozent Anke Rehlinger 41
das ist Wechselstimmung in Zahlen ja
ziemlich deutlich danke Matthias und
dann schauen wir jetzt mal nach und
fragen nach bei unseren Reportern
zunächst beiwurfschmiese der die SPD
heute Abend in den Blick nimmt und
vermutlich wohl schon jetzt viele
fröhliche Gesichter sieht oder
Bettina der Fraktionschef der SPD im
Saarland heizt hier gerade ein es ist
dem Ungläubigen Optimismus der echte
Optimismus gekommen jetzt man rechnet
damit dass da auf der Bühne die künftige
Ministerpräsidentin der SPD des
Saarlandes sprechen wird an diesem Abend
es gab ja erst zwei Ministerpräsidenten
Oskar Lafontaine und Reinhard Klimt
Klimt ist auch hier heute Abend und in
dieser Garage was jetzt eine Disco ist
das war früher die Ford Garage ein
Autohaus und das waren die Zeiten als
Lafontaine die absolute Mehrheit geholt
hat und manche glauben das könnte heute
Abend wieder so sein bald sehen was
ja Dankeschön Wolf da stellt man sich
auf einen großen Sieg schon ein und wir
gehen zur CDU und zu Kristina von Ungarn
Sternberg die CDU hat bis zuletzt darauf
gesetzt dass der Rückstand am Ende dann
doch noch aufzuholen ist aber die
letzten Umfragen haben das eben nicht
mehr gesehen stellt sich die CDU stellt
sich der Ministerpräsident jetzt schon
auf die Niederlage ein
naja Bettina die Strategie von Tobias
Hans ist eigentlich recht einfach der
sagt nämlich ich gebe nichts auf
Umfragen und wie du sagst er hofft dass
dann doch am Ende die Wählerinnen und
Wähler sich um ihren Regierungschef
versammeln in Krisenzeiten für die die
sich hier versammelt haben aus der
Bundesspitze ist keiner dabei Annegret
Kramp-Karrenbauer Peter Altmaier die
großen Namen der Saarland CDU wird man
hier heute Abend nicht sehen aber für
die die hier sind gibt es eine gut
gefüllte Bar es gibt nicht wie bei der
fdp-champagne aber immerhin Sekt die
Frage ist nur ob es heute ein Abend für
Sekt wird oder dann eher doch für
Selters Dankeschön Christina du hast das
im Blick für uns ja wir haben noch eine
Minute eine gute Minute bis zur Prognose
der Forschungsgruppe Wahlen Professor
Korte seit 1999 wird das Saarland
durchgängig von der CDU regiert das wäre
schon eine herbe Niederlage für den
Ministerpräsidenten hier wenn die SPD
ihn in dieser Weise aus dem Amt fegen
würde ja denn die SPD wurde vor fünf
Jahren gedemütigt von CDU im Moment
sieht es so aus als würde die Rollen
getauscht nach einer Demütigung und das
wäre nicht nur eine Zäsur sondern dass
wir natürlich etwas was den
Wahlkampfauftakt für die folgenden
Landtagswahlen für die CDU völlig kaputt
macht denn in der Tat stehen ja auch im
Mai weitere Wahlen an Schleswig-Holstein
Nordrhein-Westfalen und auch da stehen
CDU-Ministerpräsidenten zur Wahl genau
das ist manchmal Segen und Fluch des
Kalenders wie so Landtagswahlen
hintereinander liegen jetzt trifft es
drei Ministerpräsident es gibt noch mal
ein gegengerichteten Effekt gegen den
Bund bei zurückliegenden Wahlen mit
einem oppositionseffekt die Umfragen
deuten nicht dahin so dann gucken wir
jetzt mal wie die Prognose ist nämlich
genau in 5 Sekunden die Prognose der
Forschungsgruppe Wahlen für die
Landtagswahl im Saarland
für die CDU
27,5 sehr deutliche Verluste SPD 44
Prozent sehr starke Gewinne linke 2,5
deutliche Verluste und nicht mehr im
Landtag vertreten die AFD 5,5 leichte
Verluste wahrscheinlich knapp im Landtag
grüne 6 Prozent Gewinne und auch wohl
wieder im Landtag FDP 4,8 das sind
leichte Gewinne aber eher nicht mehr im
Parlament die anderen
9,7 Prozent so das ist doch etwas was
man sich jetzt erstmal in Ruhe anschauen
muss mit Matthias fahrndorf
Sitzverteilung und Koalition so ist es
die Sitzverteilung in der Reihenfolge
der Parteien wie sie auf den Stimmzettel
hier standen und da sehen wir die
absolute Mehrheit braucht 626 Sitze die
CDU käme auf 17 die SPD auf 28 sitze
AFD 3 und die Grünen ebenfalls 3 Sitze
wer kann mit wem reagieren da wird es
ein bisschen komplizierter wir brauchen
zwei Szenarien weil es für die FDP sie
haben es gesehen mit 4,8% sehr sehr
knapp ist mit die mit der 5% Hürde wenn
sie unter fünf Prozent bleibt dann haben
wir im Saarbrücker Landtag
glasklareverhältnisse nämlich eine
absolute Mehrheit für die SPD mit 28
sitzen hier ist die senkrechte Linie
deutlich überschritten wenn die FDP ist
aber noch über die 5% Hürde schafft dann
gibt es verschiedene Optionen dann hat
entweder die SPD immer noch eine
allerdings sehr sehr knappe absolute
Mehrheit oder sie kann natürlich als
große Koalition oder mit den Grünen oder
mit der FDP ein Bündnis bilden und für
all das würde es reichen Einblick noch
auf die Wahlbeteiligung die ist gesunken
gegenüber 2017 von 69,7 auf 63,0
so also starke Gewinne zweistellig Satz
zweistellig für die SPD und die absolute
Mehrheit jedenfalls liegt sehr nah wie
wir es gerade gesehen haben jetzt wird
das sicherlich bei der SPD hier im
Saarland gefeiert wo ich mir keine uns
das berichten
und wie das gefeiert wurde als gerade
die Prognosen gezeigt wurden nein ein
Jubel ausschrei als dann der Balken der
SPD tatsächlich weit über 40 fragte und
als dann 26 Sitze was die absolute
Mehrheit sind gezeigt wurden dann ging
hier das Gejubel los die Leute sind
völlig aus dem Häuschen das gab es
zuletzt vor über 25 Jahren in der Ära
Lafontaine Anke Rehlinger könnte die
absolute
mehrheitsministerpräsidentin die erste
der SPD im Saarland werden und das
feiert man heute Abend hier in der
Garage was eigentlich eine Disco ist und
ein bisschen die Stimmung jetzt wie in
einer Disco
in der Tat wo ich mir so vielen Dank und
jetzt können wir auch schon Nachfragen
auf Bundesebene denn ich bin verbunden
mit Kevin Kühnert dem
spd-generalsekretär Herr Kühnert schönen
guten Abend ja das ist ein spektakulärer
Erfolg muss man sagen für die SPD Anke
Rehlinger macht das Rennen ein halbes
Jahr nach der Bundestagswahl gelingt der
Machtwechsel im Saarland es ist ja auch
ihr erster Wahlabend im neuen Amt Herr
kühner keine große Herausforderung heute
oder
Jan schönen guten Abend erstmal und es
ist natürlich ein Abend der geteilten
Gefühle und da ganz schwierigen
Umständen unter den wir im Moment alle
leben ist das sie Verständnis haben für
die Sozialdemokratie ein unglaublich
toller Abend ein Erdrutschsieg für
unsere Parteifreundinnen und
Parteifreunde an der saß ist der Erfolg
der Saar SPD und von Anke Rehlinger die
wirklich Herz und Köpfe der hatten an
der Saar hat erreichen können das haben
wir auch spüren können sie hat auch die
ganze SPD insgesamt damit infiziert und
wir freuen uns natürlich dann ist es ein
Jahr in dem wir noch drei weitere
Landtagswahlen haben werden die wir
erfolgreich bestreiten wollen in
Nordrhein-Westfalen in schleswig-stein
und in Niedersachsen und das gibt uns
wahnsinnigen Rückenwind und Sie erleben
einen wirklich sehr gelösten und
freudigen spd-generalsekretär heute
Abend und wir haben in der Tat die
starken Werte von Anke Rehlinger gesehen
bei Sympathie Glaubwürdigkeit Kompetenz
ist dies vor allem Herr Kühnert auch
tatsächlich ihr Sieg oder darf sich den
auch Olaf Scholz gut schreiben
das ist ganz klar der Sieg der sah SPD
und der von Anke Rehlinger persönlich
anders sind solche Ergebnisse nicht
möglich und gleichzeitig bricht sich
niemanden Zacken aus der Krone zu sagen
dass die Bundes SPD nicht nur nicht im
Weg gestanden hat sondern natürlich auch
geholfen hat das haben sie daran gesehen
wie viel wir alle vor Ort gewesen sind
und auch mit offenen Armen empfangen
wurde denn machen wir uns nichts vor es
gab viele Zeiten in der SPD da hat man
in Landtagswahlkämpfen von der
Bundespartei Abstand gehalten und hat
versucht gegen die Bundespartei Erfolg
zu erringen und die neue SPD die
erfolgreiche SPD ist eben eine die
gemeinsam den Erfolg sucht und ihn auch
findet und deswegen freuen wir uns mit
Anke Renninger und freuen uns ein
bisschen was auch dazu beigetragen zu
haben und die Zustimmung zu
Persönlichkeiten wie Olaf Scholz Anke
Rehlinger und anderen zeigt eben im
Moment die unsicherer die Zeiten sind
desto wichtiger werden für die Menschen
persönliche Werte wie Vertrauen
Verlässlichkeit auch Berechenbarkeit und
ich glaube das sollten alle handelnden
Akteure in der Politik sich hinter die
Ohren schreiben also Freude beim
spd-generalsekret sie bleiben bei uns
ich nehme aber gerne Andreas Jung dazu
seit Januar stellvertretender
Bundesvorsitzender der CDU zweistellige
Verluste für die CDU im Saarland Herr
Jungen die SPD wir haben es gerade noch
mal gesehen gewinnt haushoch das ist ein
denkbar schlechter Staat in zwei Jahr
2022 werden trägt aus ihrer Meinung nach
dafür jetzt die Verantwortung
er verschossen zunächst einmal da gibt
es nichts zu deuten die SPD hat mit Anke
Rehlinger diese Landtagswahl gewonnen es
ist ganz maßgeblich ihr persönlicher
Erfolg hat der gerade auch Kevin Kühnert
gesagt wir gratulieren ihr dazu sie wird
Ministerpräsidentin werden wir wünschen
ihr dabei eine glückliche Hand und damit
ist Ihre Frage auch schon beantwortet es
war eine Landtagswahl und das zeigen ja
alle demografischen Befunde alle
demoskopischen Befunde die wurden
entschieden über landespolitische Themen
die sind da im Mittelpunkt gestanden die
haben den Ausschlag gegeben ja und es
ist aber in der Tat ein historisch
schlechtes Ergebnis seit 1960 war die
CDU im Saarland nicht unter 30 Prozent
der jung wir können uns gerade noch mal
die Bilder der 18 Uhr Prognose anschauen
das ist natürlich ein bitterabend für
die CDU ich gehe mal zu Christina von
Ungarn Sternberg noch mal mit der Frage
wie das aufgenommen wurde
das war tatsächlich eine Katastrophe für
die Leute die hier sind als die Bilder
die Zahlen eben haben hat überhaupt
niemand gejubelt außerdem Kollegen von
der heute-show der dann ein cdu-kollegen
hier abgeklatscht hat der glaube ich
einfach nur aus Schockstarre mit
eingeschlagen hat aber nicht weil er
sich gefreut hat das ist ein Desaster
hier für die CDU heute Abend das muss
man sagen du hast die Zahl gerade
genannt das schlechteste Ergebnis hatte
die CDU hier an der sah 1955 mit 25,4
Prozent und Tobias hans hat mal gesagt
37% ist eine Marke die die CDU braucht
als Volkspartei dabei hat er sich auf
die Bundespartei bezogen jetzt hat er
hier selbst ein desaströses Ergebnis
eingefahren und es ist natürlich die
Frage was man damit macht und das ist
nicht nur eine politische sondern auch
eine persönliche Frage Tobias hans hat
keine abgeschlossene Berufsausbildung
keinen abgeschlossenes Studium die Frage
wer jetzt hier verantwortlich gemacht
wird hier wann zurücktreten muss oder
wer vielleicht als Juniorpartner zur
Verfügung steht in einer großen
Koalition unter der SPD da gibt es viel
zu reden heute Abend ja danke für die
Eindrücke Christina Desaster haben wir
gehört es war dies Herr Jung auch die
erste Wahl unter dem neuen
Bundesvorsitzenden Friedrich Merz der
sich ja hier im Wahlkampf im Saarland
ausgesprochen rar gemacht hat warum war
damit diese absehbare Niederlage dann
nicht als seine gewertet wird
wir haben hier gemeinsam gekämpft wir
waren mit dem gesamten Bundesvorstand
bei der klausurteilung und vor Ort bei
Wahlterminen im Saarland wir haben
gemeinsam gekämpft wenn man gemeinsam
kämpft den gewinnt man zusammen und man
verliert zusammen hier ist es jetzt ein
bitterer Abend da gilt unser besonderer
Dank den Wahlkämpfern der CDU sah die
obwohl sie seit langem wussten dass
dieser Wahlkampf schwierig wird
unglaublich gekämpft hat und deshalb
werden wir es auch gemeinsam mit diesem
Ergebnis umgehen und wenn sie nach der
neuen Führung fragen da will ich doch
dazu sagen dass Friedrich Merz noch
keine 100 Tage im Amt ist und dass die
Werte auf Bundesebene auch in
Nordrhein-Westfalen auch in
Schleswig-Holstein andere sind wir sind
bei den Werten auf Bundesebene auf
Augenhöhe und es zeigt es war hier eine
Saarland Wahl dann schauen wir noch mal
nach vorne und da nehme ich gerne Kevin
Kühnert noch mal dazu Herr Kühnert die
Wahlen im Mai Schleswig-Holstein und
Nordrhein-Westfalen da stehen auch CD
Ministerpräsidenten zur Wahl wie stark
ist das Signal das heute aus dem
Saarland ausgeht für die anstehenden
Wahlen im Mai
es gibt ein ganz starkes Signal und das
ist heute noch gar nicht zur Sprache
gekommen Anke Rehlinger ist die erste
seit fünf Jahren die es jetzt haben wird
ein Bundesland zu drehen fünf Jahre ist
das her dass das letzte Mal eine
führende Regierungspartei in einem
deutschen Bundesland abgelöst wurde
dieser gordische Knoten ist nun also
durchschlagen man kann aus der
Herausforderer Position heraus
Landtagswahlen gewinnen und genau das
sorgt natürlich dafür dass wir
Zuversicht noch mal herausziehen für die
Landtagswahlen in Nordrhein-Westfalen
und in Schleswig-Holstein für Thomas
kutschati und Thomas Glosse Müller von
denen wir wollen dass Sie als nächstes
für die SPD Landeschefs werden in zwei
wichtigen und großen Bundesländern in
Deutschland und insofern ist das nicht
nur ein guter Abend für die SPD an der
Saar heute sondern für die SPD insgesamt
und wir nehmen Rückenwind aus diesem Amt
mit Jungfern an sie auch noch mal diese
Frage sie sagen die Verhältnisse in
Schleswig-Holstein und
Nordrhein-Westfalen sind andere aber ist
das nicht dann doch jetzt wirklich ein
gefährliches Omen für die maiwahlen für
die CDU
das ist kein oben das war eine
Landtagswahl und wir werden im Mai
andere Landtagswahlen haben und sie
sehen ja stand heute da gibt es ganz
andere Werte Hendrik wüst Daniel Günther
haben starke persönlichkeitswerte die
haben gewonnen in beiden Bundesländern
in den letzten Tagen in den letzten
Wochen und deshalb blicken wir
optimistisch aber natürlich mit der
gebotenen Demut auf diese Wahltermine
wir werden jetzt alles dafür tun um
gemeinsam mit den Kollegen vor Ort diese
waren vorzubereiten und dazu gehört auch
dass wir sehr klar machen wofür wir als
Opposition in Berlin und in
Regierungsverantwortung in den Ländern
stehen nämlich für Stabilität für
gemeinsame Verantwortung sagt Andreas
Jung der stellvertretende
Bundesvorsitzende der CDU und dank auch
an Kevin Kühnert spd-generalsekretär
beiden nach Berlin guten Abend noch
tschüss
so und hier im Saarland schauen wir
jetzt weiter zu den Grünen die den
Wiedereinzug geschafft haben in den
saarländischen Landtag allerdings sehr
knapp die Ferien ist dort und hat auch
schon die Spitzenkandidatin im Gespräch
ja Bettina neben mir steht nun die
Spitzenkandidatin der Grünen Lisa Becker
Frau Becker wie groß ist sie
Erleichterung 6 Prozent ist sie so aus
als hätten die Grünen Sprung in den
Landtag geschafft
natürlich dass sich das im Endergebnis
auch so widerspiegeln wird und das
Warten wir zunächst mal ab wenn es dabei
bleibt sind wir natürlich
froh über dieses Ergebnis es gab ja
viele geradenkämpfe ist die Grünen sind
die Grünen tatsächlich so geschlossen
wie sie sich jetzt zeigen wir sind
geschlossen wir haben geschlossenen
Wahlkampf gemacht zusammen unser
Wahlprogramm aufgestellt und das lässt
mich zu positiv in die Zukunft blicken
vielen Dank Lisa Becker und damit zurück
ins Wahlstudio ja also wir nehmen schon
wahr Dankeschön Eve leichter Entwarnung
bei den Grünen das geht bei der FDP noch
nicht so recht rund um die fünf Prozent
Hürde in der Prognose der
Forschungsgruppe waren leicht darunter
Karsten Rüger wie ist das aufgenommen
worden jedenfalls keinen Anlass um die
Champagnerflaschen die kalt gestellt
sind schon knallen zu lassen
ja Bettina und trotzdem wurde um punkt
18 Uhr gejubelt man muss erklären warum
weil die Kollegen der ARD 5,0 pro
Prozent vorhergesagt haben als Prognose
und da war der Jubel groß dass man
vielleicht doch im Landtag ist jetzt
können wir einfach direkt fragen ich
habe hier die Spitzenkandidatin Frau
hiedrich Peter nach der Prognose des
ZDFs sind es 4,8%, dann wären sie nicht
drin von dem Ziel 8% was sie ausgegeben
haben sowieso weit entfernt was sagen
sie na ja zunächst mal Dank in allen
Wählerinnen und Wähler die uns ihre ihr
Vertrauen geschenkt haben das ist ein
wichtiger Punkt das zweite Punkt ist
natürlich zunächst mal Gratulation an
andere Reling und an die SPD die haben
tollen Ergebnis erzielt das ganz
zweifelsohne wir sehen zunächst mal dass
in den letzten Wochen der Wahlkampf sehr
stark in der Öffentlichkeit auf die
Frage fokussiert war wer
Ministerpräsident dieses Landes wird das
hat natürlich für alle kleinen Parteien
schwer gemacht überhaupt die Wahrnehmung
zu bekommen die sie brauchen es ist
natürlich schwer gewesen für die beiden
Oppositionsparteien die jetzt schon im
Landtag drin waren die haben es ja auch
ein bisschen schwer wenn man die
Ergebnisse richtig deutet und für uns
als apo-partei war das natürlich von der
Wahrnehmung mindestens genauso schwer
aber wir sind nach wie vor
zuversichtlich dass die Prognose von der
ARD auf bestimmt dass wir mit fünf
Prozent auf jeden Fall drin sind das war
die erste wichtigste Hürde wir werden
das weiter verfolgen der
Landesvorsitzende ihre Kolleginnen
es ist so früh für Analyse wir müssen
das ganze abwarten wir werden weiterhin
unseres anschauen die Spannung auf jeden
Fall ist sehr groß genau
danke schön Carsten ja das muss man
abwarten ob die FDP jetzt in den Landtag
schafft oder nicht klar ist allerdings
das Rennen an der Spitze und zwar
glasklar da hat Anke Rehlinger von der
SPD das Rennen sehr sehr deutlich
gemacht der Machtwechsel für die SPD im
Saarland ist geschafft für die CDU ist
das ein wirklich bitterer Wahlabend und
es hat sich nicht einen Effekt
eingestellt den man bei Landtagswahlen
häufiger sieht nämlich dass sich die
Menschen doch hinter dem Amtsinhaber
versammeln genau das ist nicht geschehen
und deshalb sind Analyse Daten
interessant Matthias die Verluste der
CDU und genau damit beginnt die Analyse
der Ministerpräsident und seine
Herausforderungen macht seine Sache eher
gut Tobias Tobias Hans das Sagen 55
Prozent das klingt erstmal ganz gut ist
aber bei amtierenden Ministerpräsidenten
und ministerpräsidentinnen an eher
schwacher Wert am unteren Ende der Skala
andere hatten da Werte über 80 Prozent
und noch bitterer für Tobias Hans Anke
Rehlinger würde es besser machen das
Sagen 41 Prozent jetzt schauen wir noch
mal auf die Kandidaten und ihre Parteien
in diesem Jahr und vor fünf Jahren auf
der Skala von +5 bis -5 positive
Bewertung vorsichtig positive Bewertung
für Hans und die CDU im Saarland 1,1
aber vor fünf Jahren waren diese Werte
doppelt so hoch etwa 2,4 für Annegret
Kramp-Karrenbauer und 2,1 für die CDU im
Saarland ein letztes noch das ist die
wahltagsbefragung die Forschungsgruppe
waren hat an 130 Wahllokalen im Saarland
Wählerinnen und Wähler befragt anonym
natürlich und wir schauen uns mal die
Verluste der CDU CDU nach Alter an und
da sehen wir sie verliert durchgängig in
allen Altersgruppen am stärksten aber
bei den über 60-Jährigen was eigentlich
ihr stärkstes Klientel ist
danke schön interessante Daten von
Matthias Fornoff so und wir können jetzt
wieder eine Stimme aus Berlin hören und
zwar den Grünen
Parteivorsitzenden und mit nuripur der
mir jetzt zugeschaltet ist ja nur wir
schauen auf das Ergebnis der Grünen in
der Prognose
6 Prozent also den Wiedereinzug in den
saarländischen Landtag geschafft aber
für die Grünen war das Saarland
eigentlich immer schon ein schwieriges
Pflaster beim letzten Mal rausgeflogen
bei der letzten Bundestagswahl nicht mal
wählbar wegen innerer Streitereien ja
jetzt sieht es so aus als wären sie
wieder drin aber warum ist dann doch
nicht mehr drin
herzlichen Dank für diese wirklich gute
Frage und vor allem auch für die genaue
Beschreibung der Lage im Saarland es ist
als erstes natürlich geboten Anke
relinger für ihren großen war Erfolg
auch zu gratulieren es ist überhaupt
keine Frage sie haben beschrieben dass
wir aus einer sehr sehr schwierigen
Ausgangslage heraus in diesen Wahlkampf
gestaltet haben Lisa Becker unsere
Spitzenkandidatinnen und ihr Team haben
alles gegeben und natürlich warten wir
ab wie das Endergebnis aussieht aber es
sieht sehr gut aus dass es wieder eine
starke Stimme gibt für Klimaschutz im
Landtag im Saarland und vor allem dass
wir endlich wieder in allen Landtagen im
Bund überall vertreten sind und das ist
natürlich auch Rückenwind und
Bestätigung für die Arbeit die wir auf
Bundesebene machen wenn es bei
6,0,0 bliebe was gerade ja von ZDF
prognostiziert worden ist wäre es das
beste Ergebnis was wir da jemals hatten
ja in der Tat im Saarland waren die
Grünen noch nie sonderlich stark nur wo
sie sagen gerade Rückenwind für die
Bundespartei wie steht es denn andersrum
sie sind ja Regierungspartei im
vielleicht hätten die Grünen hier im
Saarland davon nicht mehr profitieren
müssen also warum kein Werbung kein
harbeck-bonus
es gab ja ein Bundestrend der
unterstützt hat sie kommen ja vor fünf
Jahren von vier Prozent und
zwischenzeitlich sie haben selbst
beschrieben gab es so große Verwerfungen
dass man gar nicht mehr antreten konnte
und dementsprechend ist jetzt in sehr
kurzer Zeit sehr viel aufgeholt worden
und sehr viel geleistet worden und das
ist einfach nur schön zu sehen und
erfreulich das sagen sie ist dann im
Grunde schon ein Effekt auch aus der
Bundespolitik jetzt ist noch nicht ganz
klar es sieht stark danach aus dass Anke
Rehlinger und die SPD ist hier alleine
machen kann absolute Mehrheit keinen
Partner braucht wenn die FDP noch
reinkommt ist das noch nicht ganz sicher
stimmten die Grünen in dem Fall bereit
für Rot-Grün im Saarland
der Ball liegt natürlich bei der SPD und
natürlich sind wir auch gesprächsbereit
aber heute Abend freuen wir uns erstmal
und drücken die Daumen dass auch beim
beim amtlichen Endergebnis wir klar und
deutlich über davon Prozent höher sind
Dankeschön und mit noripol war das
herzlichen Dank nach Berlin so und die
Wahlsiegerin des Abends hier im Saarland
tritt jetzt schon auf sie muss sich ja
auch keine Zeit lassen 18 Uhr 18 Anke
Rehlinger die große Siegerin des
heutigen Abends
liebe Genossinnen liebe Genossen
liebe Freundinnen liebe Freunde meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
das Saarland hat rot gewählt die sah SPD
hat die Wahl gewonnen und nach 23 Jahren
sind wir wieder stärkste Kraft als
Sozialdemokratie an der Saar
[Applaus]
das ist es ist das Ergebnis
das ist das Ergebnis
harter Arbeit in den letzten Jahren
gewesen wir haben uns das Vertrauen der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger ein Stück weit
zurückerkämpft und wir haben als Partei
insgesamt jeder von euch die
Regierungsmannschaft die
Landtagsfraktion jeder irgendwo in einem
Kommunalparlament als
Ortsvorsteher als Parteimitglied im Ort
unterwegs
Glaubwürdigkeit erarbeitet liebe
Genossinnen und Genossen und das ist
auch am heutigen Tag belohnt worden
alles das was ihr gemacht habt für das
ihr vor Ort steht das ist unser großer
gemeinsamer Erfolg an diesem Abend und
dafür ein herzliches Dankeschön
[Applaus]
so eine glückliche Siegerin haben wir da
gesehen
die hier den Erfolg zurecht feiert der
SPD des einen Erfolg ist natürlich das
anderen schaden die Linke hat hier
miserabel abgeschnitten in der Prognose
bei 2,5% noch ich bin jetzt verbunden
mit der Parteivorsitzenden der Linken
Susanne hennig-well so schön guten Abend
schönen guten Abend ja DIE LINKE im
Saarland das war ja mal die
Erfolgsgeschichte 2009 führte Oskar
Lafontaine ihre Partei hier im Saarland
zu über 20 Prozent und nun ist es die
Geschichte eines Niedergangs was ist
ihre Erklärung
zunächst ist es wirklich kein guter
Abend für uns ich gratuliere natürlich
auch der möglicherweise neuen
Ministerpräsidentin bedanke mich bei
unseren wahlkämpfenden genossen vor Ort
das Ergebnis ist mit Sicherheit
davon geprägt dass die Linke im Saarland
durchaus über die letzten Jahre heftiger
Auseinandersetzung geführt hat und es
ist wie es ist man wird keine
zerstrittenen Parteien das Ergebnis
bekommen wir heute in anderen
Deutlichkeit das ist für uns wirklich
bitter und ein Desaster und das werden
wir natürlich zusammen mit dem Saarland
besprechen weil am Ende müssen die
Genossen im Saarland den aufbrach
Aufbruch neu gestalten ja sie sprechen
den Streit an Oskar Lafontaine ist kurz
vor diesem Wahlgang aus der Politik
ausgeschieden im Streit mit der Linken
welche Rolle spielt er bei dieser
Niederlage was messen sie ihm dann
Verantwortung zu
ich glaube welche Verantwortung oskarner
von thaine hat weiß Oskar napantinen am
besten man sieht es ja an den Zahlen als
er ein Spitzenkandidat angetreten ist
und die saninke durchaus in
Geschlossenheit agiert hat in welcher
Form wir auch gewinnen konnten umso
bitterer ist es dass man ihn jetzt für
diese mal nicht mehr gewinnen konnten
bei uns als Genossen zu sein insofern
wie gesagt er weiß um seine eigene
Verantwortung die SPD mit über 40
Prozent 43 44 Prozent erlebt hier im
Saarland tatsächlich eine Renaissance
sie regiert im Bund Olaf Scholz ruft
schon einen sozialdemokratisches
Jahrzehnt aus beschleicht sie mit unter
der Gedanke dass die Linke nicht mehr
gebraucht wird
nein der beschlecht mich nicht also die
über 40 Prozent und die absolute
Mehrheit für die Sozialdemokratie im
Saarland ist beachtliches Ergebnis und
Demokratie theoretisch auch noch mal
sehr spannend wie sich das Land
entwickeln wird mit einer Partei die die
absolute Mehrheit hat für uns als Linke
war schon mit der Bundestagswahl klar
dass wir im Moment keine einfache Zeit
haben aber ob es ein
sozialdemokratisches Jahrzehnt gibt das
steht erstmal noch in den Sternen zumal
die Ampel noch große Herausforderungen
vor sich hat sagt die Vorsitzende der
Linken herzlichen Dank Frau Hennig
Welzow ja beim letzten Mal waren es noch
12,8 Prozent jetzt unter die fünf
Prozent würde woran liegt das
Analysedaten Matthias ja wir schauen uns
das mal an wir gucken auf die Kurve der
letzten Landtagswahlen und das jeweilige
Abschneiden der Linken hier im Saarland
da sehen wir 2009 das war das erste Mal
das Oskar Lafontaine als Spitzenkandidat
für die Linke angetreten ist er war ja
13 Jahre Ministerpräsident für die SPD
dann geht es zwar immer weiter roten
runter auch mit Lafontaine aber ganz
steile jetzt auf unter 5 und sogar unter
drei Prozent wir gucken uns noch eine
zweite Grafik an die Linke ist der
Aussagesatz war im Saarland nur wegen
Oskar Lafontaine so stark dem Stimmen 78
Prozent der Wahlberechtigten im Saarland
zu und wenn man uns nach anhängergruppen
angucken sind sie auch alle einig bis
auf die Anhänger der Linken selbst ja
dankeschön das nochmal interessant das
zu beobachten so und jetzt sehe ich 18
Uhr 24 haben wir Matthias wenn ich es
richtig sehe eine erste Hochrechnung gut
dann machen wir gleich weiter die erste
Hochrechnung wir schauen auf die
Prozente demnach kommt die CDU auf 27,5
Prozent die SPD auf 43,8 linke 2,6 nicht
im Landtag AFD 5,5 knapp drin grüne 5,8
etwas deutlicher drin und die FDP
haarscharf unter der 5% Hürde bei 4,9
die Reihenfolge der Parteien
sie auf den Stimmzetteln stand schauen
wir auf die Gewinne und Verluste was ich
diesmal wirklich lohnt weil es ja
kräftige Veränderungen gab die CDU
verliert 13,2% Punkte die SPD gewinnt
14,2 Punkte dazu die Linke verliert mehr
als zehn Punkte AFD mit leichten
Verlusten grüne mit etwas deutlicheren
zugewinnen ebenso die FDP die
Sitzverteilung im Landtag es gibt eine
absolute Mehrheit bei 26 sitzen die
cdu-käme auf 17 die SPD auf 28
AFD 3 und Grüne ebenfalls 3 wer kann mit
wem regieren wieder zwei Szenarien
einmal die FDP die ihr haarscharf unter
5% gerade lag in der Hochrechnung bleibt
unter fünf Prozent dann sind es sehr
klare Verhältnisse hier im Saarbrücker
Landtag mit einer absoluten Mehrheit für
die SPD diese Linie diese senkrechte
Linie 26 Stimmen muss man überschreiten
das geht dann ist die FDP doch über
Prozent dann wird es knapp für die
absolute Mehrheit es gab sie derzeit
immer noch mit der knappstmöglichen
Sitzverteilung 26 Sitzen für die SPD
genau die Zahl die man braucht für drei
weitere SPD-geführte Bündnisse würde es
eigentlich locker reichen für die große
Koalition natürlich sowieso für ein
rot-grünes Bündnis auch und auch für ein
soziale beratungsbündnis ja dankeschön
das also die erste Hochrechnung für das
Saarland der Machtwechsel ist hier in
der Tat für die SPD geschafft das was
sie sich vorgenommen hatte große
Verschiebungen ein kantersee geradezu
für Sie Sozialdemokraten wir werden die
Ergebnisse im Laufe des Abends weiter
analysieren sind mit prominenten
Gesprächspartnern verabredet darunter
SPD Parteichef Lars Klingbeil auf dem
FDP-Vorsitzenden Christian Lindner
zunächst aber nehmen wir das Thema in
den Blick das beherrschend ist in diesen
Tagen und Wochen den Krieg in der
Ukraine es beherrscht die Politik und
das beschäftigt uns alle deshalb gebe
ich jetzt ab du Antje Pieper und einem
zdf-spezial in einer guten Viertelstunde
melden wir uns hier zurück im ZDF-Studio
Antje bitte
ja vielen Dank Bettina und willkommen zu
einer kurzen Spezialsendung zum Krieg in
der Ukraine
um Gottes Willen dieser Mann kann nicht
an der Macht bleiben der Satz von
US-Präsident Joe Biden gestern in seiner
Rede in Warschau sorgt weiter für
Aufregung das Weiße Haus versucht zurück
zu rudern damit zeigt kein Aufruf zum
Sturz putinsgemeinde heißt es darüber
reden wir gleich ausführlicher zunächst
aber get Anhalt mit einem Überblick
als er spät in der Nacht nach Washington
zurückkehrte da hatte Joe Biden in
Europa ein mächtiges Ausrufezeichen
gesetzt und auch etliche Fragezeichen
hinterlassen um Gottes Willen dieser
Mann kann nicht an der Macht bleiben
der historische Satz zu Putins macht
Verbleib war noch nicht verheilt als ich
Freund und Feind fragten ob die USA
neuerdings einen Regimewechsel im Kreml
betreiben wollten kühl und machtgewiss
zeigte sich heute der Kremlchef als er
der Nationalgarde zum sechsjährigen
bestehen gratulierte
besonders denjenigen die in der Ukraine
und im dornbas an der spezialoperation
beteiligt sind möchte ich für ihren
großen Heldenmut unter gefährlichen
Bedingungen danken alle Russen sind
stolz auf Euch
ob sie das allerdings auch noch wären
wenn sie wüssten welche Art von
spezialoperationen da geführt wird darf
zumindest bezweifelt werden nach 30
Tagen im fahrtenkreuz russischer
Artillerie und Raketenwerfer sehen Teile
von harkev mittlerweile so aus und der
angeblich heldenhafter Einsatz galt von
Anfang an auch Wohngebieten und Schulen
Kriegsverbrechen sind längst mehr als
nur ein Verdacht
ich glaube sie haben hier auch
Streubomben eingesetzt
weil man oben seines Lebens nicht mehr
sicher ist sind viele Einwohner der
zweitgrößten Stadt des Landes in die
U-Bahn-Stationen geflüchtet mit dem
wenigen dass sie aus ihren Wohnungen
retten konnten haben sich 700
ausgebombte auf den Bahnsteigen und in
den Zügen eingerichtet
in einigen Stationen stehen auf beiden
Gleisen Züge da gibt es mehr
Schlafplätze und es ist auch wärmer
wir Wärme Licht und ein wenig Hoffnung
sucht in den zugigen Schutzzonen der
muss sich für den Moment mit den Klängen
des Streichorchesters begnügen
sie eröffnen mutig und trotzig das
klassik-festival der Stadt mit Werken
von Bach und Dworschak und mit der Hymne
die sie alle gegen die Invasoren
zusammenschweißt
[Musik]
die Wahrhaftigkeit wird siegen und Licht
wird die Finsternis ablösen dieses
kleine Konzert soll zeigen dass Musik
und Kunst ewig sind und dass sie nicht
verstummen
aber auch Russlands Kanonen verstummen
nicht auch nicht in den westlichen
Vororten der Hauptstadt obwohl Russland
seine Militäraktionen nun angeblich auf
den Osten des Landes konzentrieren will
bleibt doch der Westen in Gefahr wie der
jüngste Angriff auf das Tanklager bei
Lemberg zeigt
ein wenig wie ein Feuerwehreinsatz
wirkte auch der Auftritt des
us-außenministers der heute versuchte
den Ton etwas abzukühlen den sein
Präsident gestern in Warschau gesetzt
hatte
wir haben immer gesagt dass wir
nirgendwo und auch nicht in Moskau einen
regimewechselplaner
darüber kann das russische Volk
entscheiden
Präsident beiden viel mehr dass man
Putin nicht die Macht geben dürfe andere
anzugreifen
ja der Satz von Joe Biden wirft jede
Menge Fragen auf Berlin spreche ich
jetzt mit der Politologin und
us-expertin Katherine Klüver asbrook
guten Abend schönen guten Abend was ist
denn das Ziel der USA wirklich ein
Machtwechsel und Joe Biden hätte es nur
nicht laut sagen sollen nein dieser Satz
des Präsidenten war menschlich
verständlich menschlich verständlich ich
glaube sehr wohl dass es vielen
europäischen Staatschefs ähnlich geht
wie dem Präsidenten aber diplomatisch
unklug das ist in keiner Weise dass
jedenfalls nicht das explizite Ziel der
USA das Ziel dieser Reise und dieses
Präsidenten ist es in diesem Moment die
westliche Einigkeit zu beschwören das
westliche Bündnis zusammenzuhalten und
das hat er natürlich gemacht auf dieser
Reise in dem das nicht nur ein
symbolträchtiger Akt war die Teilnahme
an den verschiedenen Gipfeltreffen am
Donnerstag aber eben auch die Reise
quasi so nah an die Grenze der Ukraine
wie ein amerikanischer Staatschef
herankommen kann um eben auch die
menschliche Verbundenheit der USA mit
dem Schicksal der Ukraine noch mal
wirklich zu unterstreichen also es geht
erstmal um den Zusammenhalt des
westlichen Bündnisses die Ukraine
nachhaltig zu unterstützen das war klar
im sanktionenpaket und wo man eigentlich
deren Hilfspaket aber eben auch noch mal
zu tief zu verankern die USA ist der
dreh- und Angelpunkt des westlichen
Bündnisses ja wie bewerten Sie die
Europa-Reise US-Präsidenten hat er seine
Ziele die sie gerade beschrieben haben
durchsetzen können einen heiden muss man
das als Erfolg werden er hat eben nicht
nur ein Symbolcharakter oder dieser
Besuch hatte eben nicht nur
Symbolcharakter sondern er kam mit
konkreten Paketen konkreten Angeboten
auch gegenüber der Europäischen Union
denn da könnte es natürlich jetzt
bröckeln wenn es um das ganze Thema Öl
und Gas embargo möglicherweise geht oder
kann ein können sich die Europäer
zusammenraufen so wie die USA in Vorlage
gegangen ist um zu sagen wir schneiden
quasi den die Öl- und Gasimporte
Russlands ab wie kann Europa da
zusammenhalten schwierige Entscheidungen
treffen daher war es eben wichtig dass
freitagmorgens noch mal diese Sig dieses
Signal kam die EU und die USA würden
auch bei der großen Energiefrage
zusammenstehen das heißt der Präsident
hat einiges mitgebracht in die Gespräche
in Brüssel und der hat sich eben auch
als ja als starkes Rückgrat dieser
westlichen Allianz gezeigt indem man bei
seinen eigenen Truppen war aber der eben
dem er auch gesprochen hat mit
Flüchtlingen denn das erste Mal hat die
USA von vornherein gesagt sie nehmen
100.000 Flüchtlinge auf also er
präsentiert sich wirklich als die
Leitfigur im westlichen Bündnis vielen
Dank für diese Einschätzung nach Berlin
und dann fragen wir auch in Moskau nach
dort ist für uns Isabel Thymian Isabel
wie sind denn die Reaktionen in Russland
auf die Reise Joe bidens und diesen Satz
Putin dürfe nicht an der Macht bleiben
tja der Creme reagierte heute kühl auf
diese Äußerung von beiden nach einem
möglichen Regimewechsel Kremel Sprecher
die Mitri pescov meinte das sei ja wohl
Sache des russischen Volkes und nicht
das amerikanischen Präsidenten zu
bestimmen wer hier in Russland gewählt
sei und Parlamentssprecher walodine
kommentierte das heute auf telegram und
meinte beiden sei schwach krank und
unglücklich und riet ihm zu
medizinischer Hilfe im russischen
Staatsfernsehen gab es dazu heute
keinerlei Statements lediglich einen
Bericht über die Rede von Joe Biden und
darüber dass er sich mehrfach
versprochen habe so habe er zum Beispiel
Mario Paul falsch ausgesprochen er habe
Metropol gesagt und er habe auch den
russischen rubelkurs falsch beziffert
ansonsten war diese entsprechende
Passage Passage oder diese entscheidende
Passage im russischen Staatsfernsehen
gar nicht erwähnt und auf Vladimir Putin
selbst hat sich offiziell dazu nicht
geäußert man will also wohl hier die
Gesprächskanäle weiter halten und hat
diese Äußerung beides hier in Moskau
nicht hart retourniert vielen Dank nach
Moskau Isabel Thymian
und dann blicken wir noch einmal in die
Ukraine Manuela Konrad hat Kontakt
aufgenommen zu einem medizinischen
Zentrum in Kiew freiwillige dort
erzählen wie sie bei der Versorgung von
Krankenhäusern helfen und bei der
Evakuierung aus umkämpften Gebieten
ein selbstgebasteltes rotes Kreuz muss
ausreichen in der Hoffnung Heil
durchzukommen die Männer aus dem
medizinischen Zentrum in Kiew bringen
ein altes Ehepaar in Sicherheit der
bettlekige Mann soll es auf dem Rücksitz
des Transporters für die lange Fahrt in
die Westukraine so angenehm wie möglich
haben seine Frau ist besorgt
wir verlassen Kiew weil wir Angst haben
dass es hier genauso wird wie in
mariopol
er hat den Zweiten Weltkrieg schon
erlebt und fürchtet sich vor einem
Dritten
es ist nur eine einzige Person die auf
den Knopf drücken kann dieser Teufel
erhält die ganze Welt in Angst weil er
den Finger auf dem Knopf hat
100% Leben so heißt die größte
Patientenorganisation in der Ukraine
ursprünglich gegründet für Menschen die
HIV positiv sind jetzt im Krieg helfen
sie allen die Hilfe brauchen ein Stab
von Freiwilligen Ärzten Medizinern und
Helfern sie sammeln Medikamente und
Medizinprodukte aus aller Welt und
verteilen sie an die Krankenhäuser
[Musik]
außerdem bauen wir Versorgungsketten auf
um Menschen mit warmen Speisen zu
versorgen Krankenhäuser Checkpoints
Armeeangehörige und bedürftige Menschen
die durch die Umstände in Not geraten
sind und sich selbst nicht mit Essen
versorgen können
Mascha moskallitz versucht im Chaos den
Überblick zu behalten eigentlich führt
sie Bergtouren durch die Karpaten jetzt
im Krieg sortiert sie nun Kisten mit
Medikamenten
die Nachfrage ist groß und die
Arzneimittel kommen nicht nur aus der
Ukraine sondern auch aus Israel
Deutschland und alles in verschiedenen
Sprachen deshalb haben wir hier einen
Stab wo die Leute sortieren wir googeln
viel und die Ärzte helfen uns auch
anhand des Wirkstoffes zu sortieren
der Zusammenhalt ist riesig die Aufgabe
auch 38 Tonnen haben sie bereits
ausgeliefert an Krankenhäuser NGOs und
Einheiten der territorialen Verteidigung
am Ende des Tages die gute Nachricht das
ältere Ehepaar hat die Stadt riffene im
Westen der Ukraine sicher erreicht
[Musik]
ja und dort in rifne zwischen Lemberg
und Kiew ist für uns Jörg Brase Jörg wie
ist denn die Lage bei Ihnen
also auch hier im Westen hat es heute
wohl wieder einige Luftangriffe gegeben
wir waren in der Stadt
chirot mir und das ist ungefähr 150
Kilometer westlich der Hauptstadt Kiosk
auch dort da gab es heute mehrfach
Luftalarm und da mussten wir uns dann
auch in die Keller begeben die Stadt
wird gerade ausgebaut zu einer Art
Festung also wir konnten beobachten wie
inshitomir Sandsäcke befüllt werden es
gab überall massive Panzersperren an den
Kreuzungen an den Ausfallstraßen
skitomir ist eine der der
hauptversorgungsa dann kann man sagen
Richtung Kiew für Bada laufen viele
Nachschublinien deshalb wurde die Stadt
auch schon mehrfach aus der Luft
angegriffen wir haben heute mit dem
Bürgermeister uns getroffen und uns mit
ihm unterhalten der erzählte uns dass er
eigentlich nicht damit rechnet dass es
ein taktikwechsel gibt der russischen
Truppen darüber war ja in den
vergangenen Tagen
spekuliert worden sondern man bereitet
sich inshitomio darauf vor dass es
eventuell auch eine Bodenoffensive geben
könnte der Bürgermeister sagt uns dass
man eher glaube dass die russischen
Truppen Atem holen sich neu organisieren
um dann eventuell auch am Boden
anzugreifen man will auf alles
vorbereitet sein wir haben auch mit
Militärs gesprochen und die sagten uns
wie überhaupt alle mit denen wir in den
vergangenen Tagen gesprochen haben dass
sie glauben dass dieser militärische
Konflikt noch eine ganze Zeit lang
weitergehen wird vielen Dank Jörg braase
und alles Gute in die Ukraine
Präsident Frank Walter Steinmeier sprach
heute von einer Katastrophe wir sind
Europa seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg nicht
mehr gegeben hat es kämen auch auf die
Menschen in Deutschland härtere Tage zu
das herrscht Krieg in Europa
das war es von uns und wir geben jetzt
schnell wieder ab zur saarlandwahl und
Bettina Schausten
ja Dankeschön Antje für dieses
zdf-spezial und zurück im ZDF Wahlstudio
die erste Landtagswahl in diesem Jahr
ein halbes Jahr nach der Bundestagswahl
und sie bringt so viel es klar einen
Haus hohensieg für die SPD Machtwechsel
im Saarland nachdem das Land fast 23
Jahre CDU geführt regiert wurde an der 5
Prozent wurde Hürde wird noch gerangelt
deshalb zunächst eine ganz frische
Hochrechnung Matthias Horner vielen Dank
hier ist sie Hochrechnung 1839 die
Parteien in der Reihenfolge wie sie auf
den Stimmzetteln hier standen CDU 27,8
sehr große Verluste SPD
43,5% sehr deutlich stärkste Partei mit
starken zugewinnen die Linke 2,5%
deutlich nicht im Landtag und sehr hohe
Verluste die AFD 5,5 Prozent ist wohl
drin mit leichten Verlusten die Grünen
mit 5,8 noch etwas deutlicher drin und
zu gewinnen und die FDP derzeit ganz
knapp unter 5% bei 4, neun Prozent zehn
Prozent auch das ist relativ viel andere
Parteien das sind 12 Parteien die aber
alle relativ klein sind die stärkste die
Tierschutzpartei kommt auf zwei Prozent
ja ein kantersee geradezu für die SPD
vermutlich absolute Mehrheit in Berlin
bin ich jetzt mit Lars Klingbeil
verbunden dem Bundesvorsitzenden der
Sozialdemokraten ja der klingen bei es
sind Kriegszeiten in Europa das fordert
die Politik in ungeahnter Weise und
lässt ja vieles unbedeutend wirken aber
welchen Wert hat gleichwohl dieser
Wahlsieg im Saarland für die SPD für Sie
als Parteichef und welche Botschaft
leiten sie daraus ab
also Sie haben recht es sind
herausfordernde Zeiten wir alle gucken
auf die Ukraine wir sehen diesen
furchtbaren Krieg dort und deswegen
fällt es auch ein bisschen schwer sich
an einem solchen Abend so zu freuen wie
man sich vielleicht in normalen Zeiten
freuen würde aber es ist ein wahnsinnig
toller Erfolg den Anke Rehlinger den die
SPD dort im Saarland eingefahren haben
nach 23 Jahren schafft man es die
CDU-Führung abzulösen das ist vor allem
der Erfolg von Anke Rehlinger die eine
unfassbar starke Ministerin
Vizeministerpräsidentin war und gefühlt
war sie eigentlich schon die
Ministerpräsidentin und jetzt wird sie
es offiziell und auch Lieferdienst von
Olaf Scholz
wir haben in Berlin unterstützt wir
waren alle da Saskia esken ich Kevin
Kühnert Rolf Mütze nicht auch Olaf
Scholz war als Bundeskanzler im
Wahlkampf hat mit unterstützt und wissen
sie es hat sich ein bisschen das
fortgesetzt was bei der Bundestagswahl
schon erfolgreich war die SPD hat als
Team zusammengestanden wir standen
geschlossen wir haben uns konzentriert
auf die Themen für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger wichtig sind und deswegen glaube
ich was auch ein Erfolg mit der
Bundespartei aber vor allem haben die
Menschen im Saarland entschieden wer
künftig das Saarland führen soll und da
lautet die Antwort sehr klar Anke
Rehlinger ja und deshalb ist die Frage
interessant ist das jetzt hier ein Omen
eine Signalwirkung für die maiwahlen in
Schleswig-Holstein und NRW auch dort
will die SPD ja CDU-Ministerpräsidenten
ablösen
wissen Sie viele haben nach der
Bundestagswahl gesagt das war einmalig
und jetzt sehen wir dass das Comeback
der SPD bei der Bundestagswahl auch
darin besteht Landtagswahlen zu gewinnen
und das nehmen wir uns natürlich auch
für die weiteren Landtagswahlen in
diesem Jahr vor wir wollen den Wechsel
in Schleswig-Holstein wir wollen den
Wechsel Nordrhein-Westfalen wir wollen
in Niedersachsen mit Stefan weil eine
erfolgreiche Ministerpräsidenten im Amt
halten dafür unterstützen wir dafür
kämpfen wir und heute waren gute Auftakt
für dieses Wahljahr 2022 der
SPD-Bundesvorsitzende Lars Klingbeil
herzlichen Dank nach Berlin ja und dann
gehen wir weiter zur CDU bei der
Bundes-CDU gibt man sich heute Abend
ziemlich verschlossen wie man auch hier
im Wahlkampf nicht jedenfalls nicht mit
großer Prominenz aufgetreten ist Daniel
pontzen ist in Berlin und kann uns
vielleicht erklären was das zum
Hintergrund hatte jedenfalls hatte man
das Gefühl die Bundesspitze rund um
Friedrich Merz hatte nicht allzu großes
Interesse am Saarland
ja offiziell hieß es dazu aus dem Konrad
Adenauer Haus aus der Parteizentrale
hier hinter mir das ist erstens rein
landespolitische Themen gewesen sein die
im Wahlkampf eine Rolle gespielt hätten
und zweitens habe man sich aus dem
Saarland auch gar keine größere
Unterstützung gewünscht habe die gar
nicht nachgefragt wieder logistisch noch
etwa durch zusätzliche Auftritte von
Friedrich Merz einmal ist er dort
gewesen vor etwa drei Wochen aber
natürlich weiß ich inoffiziell auch
jeder hier das Friedrich Merz auch kein
besonders großes Interesse daran hatte
besonders eng in Verbindung gebracht zu
werden mit diesem Wahlergebnis im
Saarland denn es hatte sich ja schon
früh abgezeichnet das ist kein besonders
gutes Ergebnis werden würde und dadurch
doch ein ziemlich starken Kontrast zu
seinen eigenen zuletzt doch guten
Ergebnissen stand persönlichen
Ergebnissen bei der Wahl zum
Parteivorsitz und dann auch zum
Fraktionsvorsitz also von der
Aufbruchstimmung die sich viele in der
Union versprochen hatten weil da nicht
wahnsinnig viel zu spüren aber es gab
dann auch noch mal den Hinweis für dich
mehr Zeit genau 13 Tage im Amt gewesen
als Parteivorsitzender ganz offenbar
jemand noch mal ganz genau nachgezählt
und die Botschaft die damit schwingt
also 13 Tage bevor die Briefwahl begann
die Botschaft die da mitschwingt es war
eben eine klare Tobias hanswahl und
keine Friedrich Merz Wahl das soll die
Botschaft sein des heutigen Abends danke
für die Erläuterung Daniel pontzen nach
Berlin so und jetzt schauen wir noch mal
aufs Ergebnis der FDP die kann noch
nicht beruhigt sein sie schwankt hier im
Saarland rund um die fünf Prozent Hürde
in Berlin ist mir Christian Lindner der
FDP Bundesvorsitzende zugeschaltet Junge
am tell Lindner
guten Abend Frau Schausten ja seit zehn
Jahren nicht im Landtag vertreten das
ist natürlich jetzt das große Ziel ist
wieder zu schaffen inzwischen regieren
sie aber im Bund mit warum ist da nicht
mehr Schwung entstanden für einen dann
doch klaren Erfolg der Liberalen heute
Abend
naja warten wir das doch bitte ab Frau
Schausten wenn man sieht die FDP hat die
Chance in den Landtag einzuziehen nach
zehn Jahren Apo also das ist eine schon
beachtliche Ausgangssituation klar der
Abend ist noch nicht zu Ende aber wir
sind auf dem richtigen Weg und hoffen
natürlich dass wir es schaffen nun haben
wir gesehen dass die CDU im Saarland
zweistellige Verluste verbucht warum
konnte davon die FDP nicht stärker
profitieren
ganz offensichtlich war es ja eine
Auseinandersetzung an der Wahlurne
zwischen Herrn Hans und Frau Rehlinger
und Frau Rehlinger muss man ja
gratulieren sie hat sehr stark zugelegt
sich auch noch weiter gelöst vom
Bundestrend also sie ist ganz gewiss die
Wahl Gewinnerin des Abends bei Grünen
und FDP ist die Lage anders wir sind da
um die fünf Prozent unterwegs ich schaue
auf die FDP und sage mit der schwierigen
Ausgangslage eine eines Jahrzehnts der
ausfahrparlamentarischen Opposition in
einer für uns sehr ungewöhnlichen
Konstellation auf der Bundesebene die
Ampel ist ja für uns eine ungewöhnliche
Konstellation haben wir trotzdem
zugelegt und möglicherweise wird ein
Jahrzehnt ohne liberale Stimme im
Parlament jetzt ja auch zu Ende gehen
Angelika hieseich Peter und unserer
Spitzenkandidatin wäre das sehr zu
Wünschen ja die Chance ist noch da Herr
Lindner das Saarland ist durch seine
Stahl und Autoindustrie geprägt hohe
Energiepreise machen den Menschen über
alle aber hier natürlich auch Sorgen mit
Blick auf die Wirtschaft auf den
privaten Geldbeutel deshalb auch die
Frage heute Abend an den
Bundesfinanzminister hat dieses letzte
Woche jetzt geschnürte Entlastungspaket
für das sie ja immer in 17 Milliarden
Euro aufwenden die Menschen am Ende
nicht wirklich überzeugt sie wollten ja
mit ihrem Tankrabatt einen durchaus
anderen Weg gehen
nein ich wollte da keinen anderen Weg
gehen sondern ich wollte auch eine
Zapfsäule eine Entlastung erreichen und
das ist ja ein beschlossen worden
technisch auf einem anderen Weg aber mit
dem Ergebnis dass ich auch wollte
übrigens die Spitzenkandidatin der SPD
Frau Rehlinger wollte das ja genauso die
hat das ja genauso öffentlich
vorgetragen und deshalb würde ich sagen
wenngleich auch nicht gleich verteilt so
ist doch die Politik der Ampelkoalition
an der Saar jedenfalls bestätigt worden
sehr stark bei Frau Rehlinger aber auch
SPD aber auch Grüne und FDP haben
profitiert insgesamt glaube ich aber
Frau Schausten dass man den
bundespolitischen Einfluss auf dieses
Wahlergebnis jetzt nicht zu groß
bemessen sollte das zeigen ja die
persönlichen Umfragewerte von Frau
Rehlinger etwa sagt der
fdp-bundesvorsitzende Christian Lindner
herzlichen Dank
so und dann schauen wir noch mal auf
diesen Erfolg der SPD und von Anke
Rehlinger auch dazu haben wir
interessante Analysedaten wem traut man
am ehesten zu Probleme zu lösen das
haben wir gefragt
Arbeitsplätze SPD 150 CDU nur 21 Prozent
Infrastruktur die SPD klar von
Wirtschaft die SPD klar von das sind
hochinteressante Daten weil es
normalerweise und auch vor fünf Jahren
genau andersrum war und jetzt schauen
wir noch mal woher woher kamen
eigentlich die Wähler der SPD diesmal
also von denen die jetzt SPD gewählt
haben haben 2017 bereits SPD gewählt
etwa 105.000 und aus allen anderen
Lagern sammelt die SPD aber auch ein am
meisten von der CDU 45.000 von der
Linken 25.000 und von den Nichtwählern
20.000 so also kommt der SPD Erfolg
zustande
danke schön Matthias so im Reigen der
bundespolitischen Stimmen bin ich jetzt
verbunden mit Tino krupala
Bundesvorsitzender der AFD der uns aus
seiner sächsischen Heimat Weißwasser
zugeschaltet ist schon genannt Herr
Koala
guten Abend Frau Scholz so wir schauen
noch mal schnell
5,55,6 jetzt in den Hochrechnungen beim
letzten Mal waren es ja an der Saar gut
sechs Prozent für die AFD das Wahlziel
ist damit nicht erreicht sie wollten
natürlich etwas mehr schaffen woran
lagst dass das nicht geklappt hat
mit dem positiven anfangen die AFD ist
wieder in den saarländischen Landtag
also eine Freiheitspartei die für im
Freiheit aber auch für Meinungsfreiheit
eintritt wird wieder im saarländischen
Landtag vertreten sein gleichwohl ist es
haben ja auch die Vorredner schon gesagt
sicherlich für die kleinen Parteien
schwierig hier Zugewinne zu erzielen wir
hätten uns sicherlich ein zwei Prozent
mehr gewünscht das wird mir jetzt
auswerten wir werden mal den Wahlamt
abwarten aber insgesamt bin ich erstmal
zufrieden dass wir wieder als Korrektiv
in im saarländischen Landtag vertreten
sind sie sind zufrieden womit sie
wahrscheinlich nicht zufrieden sind und
nicht sein können ist ein Tief
zerstrittener Landesverband den auch Sie
als Bundesvorsitzender nicht befrieden
konnten nicht mal einen
Spitzenkandidaten konnte die AFD hier
aufbieten warum haben sie das nicht in
den Griff bekommen
ja das mag vielleicht an der Saarländer
Bevölkerung ein Stück weit auch liegen
aber auch nach saarländischen AFD ein
Stück weit liegen sicherlich wir werden
jetzt das Besteck wechseln wir werden
jetzt von Gabel und Messer zum Löffel
wechseln das heißt wir werden jetzt
Schaufeln dass wir als
Opposition hier wirklich pragmatisch
arbeiten dass wir hier im Landtag eine
wichtige Arbeit leisten das haben die
letzten 5 Jahre im übrigen sehr gut
getan es ist ja auch wichtig dass wenn
vielleicht sogar wir als einzige
Opposition im saarländischen Landtag ist
sind dass wir dort auch diese
Oppositionsarbeit betreiben wir haben
viele Themen die im Saarland auch im
bundesdeutschen Schnitt ja mit vorhanden
sind das ist die hohe Inflation dass der
Strukturwandel der auch das Saarland
betrifft Autoindustrie Auto Ziel
lieferindustrie also von daher ist es
wichtig dass es hier in der AFD gibt und
das werden wir jetzt mit den Kandidaten
die in den sammelnischen Landtag
einziehen auch klären dass es hier zu
einer geschlossenen Arbeit kommt und
dass man sich hier ein Stück weit die
nächsten fünf Jahre auch konsolidiert
nimmt sich die AFD vor Tino coppala war
das der Bundesvorsitzende vielen Dank
nach Weißwasser
so dann bündeln wir doch mal kurz
Professor Korte ist da das ist schon ein
spektakulärer spd-erfolg den wir hier
heute Abend erleben ein Triumph für die
SPD die ein bisschen die Grundmelodie
weiterspielt von der Bundestagswahl
offenbar
Sozialstaatlichkeit
staatsbedürftigkeit mehr Regeln weniger
das marktliche aber diese
personenkomponente das zeigen die Daten
ja sind
wahrscheinlich ausschlaggebend für
dieses enorme Wahlergebnis was so in
dieser Form wäre gar nicht erwartbar war
war also heißt das im Grunde Anke
Rehlinger schlicht die überzeugende
Kandidatin ja der Typus ihm diesen
Krisen vielfach Krisenzeiten ist ein
anderer nicht die kümmererin sondern die
Macherin also
irritationsfest
überraschungsfrei geradezu Taten durstig
etwas vorzu
abzubilden das ist in der Tat im Moment
so im Zentrum dass man nicht mehr das
alte im der Landesmutter haben möchte
und das ist etwas anderes was
hinzugekommen ist in diesem
Persönlichkeitsfaktoren
verantwortungsvoll mit verlässlicher
Autorität zu agieren nicht nur kümmern
und das unterscheidet sie ganz offenbar
in der Wählergunst zwischen dem heraus
zwischen dem Ministerpräsidenten der
Vorzug der Wirtschaftsministerin die sie
hier schon lange Jahre ist so und jetzt
höre ich sie bleiben bei uns eine
Hochrechnung haben wir Matthias feuner
so sieht's aus und da ist jetzt
zumindest für einige Parteien noch sehr
spannend ist gucken wir uns die direkt
an 18:53 Uhr die cdu-käme auf 27,9% mit
deutlichem Verlusten die SPD stärkste
Partei 43,2 mit sehr großen Gewinnen die
Linke 2,5% riesige Verluste nicht mehr
im Landtag die AFD auch mit leichten
Verlusten bleibt aber drin mit 5,4
Prozent die Grünen etwas stärker auch
drin und mit zugewinnen und die FDP nach
wie vor hat die Forschungsgruppe Wahlen
für uns knapp unter fünf Prozent bei 4,9
Prozent mit zu gewinnen 10,3%
sonstige die aber alle unter bei zwei
Prozent oder weniger sind jetzt schauen
wir auf die Sitzverteilung die absolute
Mehrheit liegt bei 26 sitzen die CDU
käme auf 18 die SPD auf 27 die AFD F3
und die Grünen auch auf drei und schauen
auf die Koalitionsmöglichkeiten die sich
daraus ergeben sie haben es gesehen die
FDP haben wir ganz knapp unter fünf
Prozent das kann sich noch ändern im
Laufe dieses Abends käme ist aber so
dass sie nicht im Landtag ist dann hat
die SPD eine klare absolute Mehrheit
hier im Saarbrücker Landtag 27 Stimmen
wenn die FDP über den fünf Prozent ist
und im Landtag vertreten dann wird es
ganz knapp für die absolute Mehrheit die
würde sie gerade so noch kriegen 26
Sitze und alle anderen drei
Möglichkeiten die die SPD dann noch
hätte haben klare Mehrheiten die große
Koalition natürlich sowieso aber auch
Rot-Grün mit 29 sitzen und soziale
Bereich mit 29 hätten dann wenn die FDP
eben drin ist eine Mehrheit hier also
Triumph für die SPD absolute danach
sieht es aus jetzt wollen wir mal
schnell hören wie das hier heute Abend
bei den Wählerinnen und Wälder im
Saarland schon aufgenommen worden ist
Carsten Behrendt ist hier in Saarbrücken
unterwegs
wir sind auf dem St johanner Markt im
Herzen von Saarbrücken und bei mir sind
drei die heute gewählt haben vorher
Malle sie bekommen eine
Ministerpräsidentin von der SPD wie
finden sie das ja ich finde das ganz gut
ich habe die SPD ja auch gewählt und
unsere Ministerpräsidentin
sie ist also sie ist schon kaputt
kompetent und macht die Sache gut was
ich etwas vielleicht dass man nicht ganz
so gut gefällt also sie ist mir ein
bisschen zu bestimmend sagen wir mal
aber sonst im großen ganze alles gut bin
zufrieden ja hallo Mann Frau Lohmann sie
sind vor 20 Jahren aus Hamburg
eingewandert hier ins Saarland was sagen
Sie zu diesem Wahlergebnis ich bin
zufrieden entspricht meiner Wahl und ja
ich bin
glauben Sie denn dass das Anke
hillingers Erfolg ist oder hat sie auch
Rückenwind aus dem Bund bekommen ich
denke beides also auf jeden Fall auch
Unterstützung vom Bund und ihre Arbeit
ist aber auch gut okay vielen dank das
waren drei Stimmen von 5000
Wahlberechtigten hier im Saarland und
damit zurück ins ZDF-Studio ja
Dankeschön an Carsten Behrendt über den
SPD Erfolg haben wir schon geredet
Professor kordian gucken wir noch mal
auf die Schlappe der CDU die ja wirklich
hier einen bitteren Abend erlebt ist das
würden sie es so werden auch ein
schlechtes Omen für die weiteren Wahlen
die wir im Mai haben auch da stehen ja
in Schleswig-Holstein und
Nordrhein-Westfalen
CDU-Ministerpräsidenten zur Wahl ja den
offenbar greift der klassische
oppositionseffekt nicht den wir kennen
aus dem Bund dass man dann etwas anderes
wählen möchte das kann durch den Krieg
überlagert sein aber auch durch andere
Faktoren entscheidend ist ja wenn wir
auf die Personenwahl gucken ob bei den
kommenden Wahlen diese Tat Menschen
aktiv anstehen oder ob er der Kümmerer
Typus wieder eine große Rolle spielt
also die Personen Vertrauen in eine
verlässliche Autorität wird eine ganz
große Rolle spielen dass die
Parteiensysteme sich zentraler agieren
das hat man heute gesehen sogar viel
Parteien Seite kennt man bald nicht mehr
so kommt in der Renaissance der
Volksparteien gar nicht aus dem Staunen
heraus ganz traditionell wenig Parteien
und in der Mitte sehr zentriert
jedenfalls hier im Saarland das ist in
der Tat so wir haben heute abend gesehen
dass man bei der Bundes-CDU sehr bemüht
war diese Niederlage wirklich im
Saarland zu lassen um sie sozusagen gar
nicht Friedrich Merz zuschreiben zu
können ja das ist genauso denn da wird
wie so eine Festung geradezu aufgebaut
das ist ein regionales Problem ist weil
man natürlich Ansteckungsgefahren
wittert aber für mobilisiere auf der
Straße in den anstehenden wahlländern
ist das schon ein großes Problem mit
vielen Rückenwind jetzt agieren zu
können auch wenn die Umfragedaten in
beiden Ländern die anstehen für die CDU
Ministerpräsidenten viel besser aussehen
als hier gut zwei Minuten haben wir bis
zu unserer 19 Uhr Sendung dann haben wir
noch Zeit doch noch mal auf die kleinen
Parteien zu gucken wie es hier eben sehr
sehr schwer haben die FDP ist noch nicht
ganz gesichert heute Abend die link hat
geradezu einen Absturz erlebt die mal
mal sehr stark hier gerade im Saarland
mit Oskar Lafontaine das ist im Grunde
eine ein gescheitertes Projekt fast
komplett wie verbrannte Erde was er
hinterlassen hat am Schluss noch
hinterher zu treten aus der Partei
auszutreten hat natürlich der Partei
geschadet hier ist ja fast wie eine
Kommunalwahl jeder kennt jeden es wird
nicht die Parteifarbe primär gewählt
sondern die Zufriedenheit mit einzelne
Personen und da ist klar geworden bei
den kleinen Parteien sind zwar Personen
aber sind zerstritten sind nicht einig
und das spüren die Menschen unabhängig
von Parteifarbe und da hat es desaströs
die Linke getroffen
würden sie Herrn Lindner zustimmen der
vorhin bei uns im Interview gesagt hat
dass im Grunde die ampelparteien die auf
bundespolitischer Ebene jetzt natürlich
regieren hier auch gestärkt worden sind
sehr wohlwollende Interpretation aus
seiner Sicht verständlich und unter den
zahlen wenn man die Strich ziehen hat er
recht aber es kommt natürlich nicht so
an weil außerordentlich eine Partei
triumphiert die und die anderen so
gerade es schaffen praktisch in das
Parlament vielleicht zu kommen
Dankeschön Professor Korte so eine
Minute vor unserer 19 Uhr Sendung ist
der Ministerpräsident Tobias Hans schon
zu uns gekommen schönen guten Abend so
wir haben gerade noch eine Minute reden
dann in der 19 Uhr Sendung weiter ein
bitterer Abend wie enttäuscht sind sehen
natürlich ist das eine ganz herbe
Niederlage und da ist die gesamte CDU
sah natürlich enttäuscht nach 22,5
Jahren erfolgreiche Regierungszeit ist
es einfach nur bitter wenn dann die
Umfragen sich jetzt auch bestätigen im
Wahlergebnis das ist eine schwere
Niederlage hatten Sie das Gefühl
genügend über ein Unterstützung zu haben
gerade auch in den Bundesparteien hier
im Saarland
schauen Sie jetzt in so einer Situation
nach anderen zu schauen und zu Keilen
das ist nicht mein Stil das war es nie
was ich aber erlebt habe ist das aus dem
gesamten Bundesgebiet über die Phase des
Wahlkampfs Menschen gekommen sind aus
der Partei eine Tierärztin aus dem
brandenburgischen junge Menschen aus
allen Bundesländern von der Jungen Union
die uns unterstützt haben das hat uns
sehr gut getan diese Rückendeckung
weiter in
der neu-sendung denn ich gebe Punkt 19
Uhr jetzt direkt ab nach Mainz
[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg der erste Wahlsonntag
dieses Jahres guten Abend und Willkommen
an meiner Seite ist Katja streso für den
Sport guten Abend und das sind die
wichtigsten Nachrichtenthemen dieses
Sonntags
das Saarland wird rot mit großem Abstand
gewinnt die SPD bei der Landtagswahl und
kann die CDU nach über 20 Jahren als
stärkste Kraft ablösen
[Applaus]
Angriffe auf Treibstofflager Russland
bombardiert in der Ukraine öldepots
damit die Verteidiger vom Nachschub
abgeschnitten werden
und die Tafeln schlagen Alarm kostenlose
Lebensmittel für Bedürftige werden knapp
weil es immer mehr Andrang gibt und
gleichzeitig immer weniger zu verteilen
ein Paukenschlag kommt da aus dem
Saarland die SPD mit ihrer Frontfrau
Anke Rehlinger jubelt über einen Haus
hohen Wahlsieg nach zehn Jahren großer
Koalition kann sie vielleicht sogar mit
absoluter Mehrheit allein regieren weit
abgeschlagen ist die CDU mit noch
Ministerpräsident Tobias Hans die Grünen
sind wohl knapp drinnen im Landtag alle
anderen Parteien sind raus oder müssen
noch bangen Matthias Frauen auf im
wahlstudie in Saarbrücken hat die
aktuellen Zahlen und die sind deutlich
Matthias so sieht es aus guten Abend
hier kommt die nächste Hochrechnung
Punkt 19 Uhr in der Reihenfolge der
Parteien wie sie auf den Stimmzetteln
hier stand die CDU
28,0 die SPD
43,2% deutlich stärkste Partei DIE LINKE
sicher nicht mehr im Parlament vertreten
2,5 die AFD 5,4 Prozent wäre drin die
Grünen 5,5% ebenso und bei der FDP ist
es ganz ganz knapp mit 4,9% sehen wir
sie im Moment knapp unter der Singapur
Prozent Hürde wir schauen mal nach
Gewinnen und Verlusten was sich bei so
viel Bewegung in parteienverhältnis
absolut lohnt die CDU verliert mehr als
zwölf Punkte die SPD gewinnt mehr als 13
Punkte die Linke verliert zehn Punkte
die AFD verliert ein kleines bisschen
die Grünen gewinnen etwas deutlicher
hinzu ebenso die FDP ob es reicht wie
gesagt ist trotzdem nicht klar und auch
bei den anderen gibt es Zugewinn das
insgesamt 12 kleine Parteien keine von
denen hat mehr als zwei Prozent diese
Verteilung im Saarbrücker Landtag die
absolute Mehrheit liegt bei 26 sitzen
CDU käme auf 18 die SPD auf 27 die AFD
auf drei und die Grünen ebenfalls auf
drei und jetzt schauen wir darauf was
das heißen kann fürs Regieren hier im
Saarland und da haben wir zwei Szenarien
die FDP unter fünf Prozent da hatten wir
sie gerade noch haarscharf wenn das so
käme hätte die SPD eine absolute
Mehrheit mit 27 sitzen ist also über
dieser senkrechten Linie von 26 Sitz
wenn man mindestens braucht werden die
FDP aber noch reinkommt und über fünf
Prozent kriegt dann wird es knapp dann
hätte die SPD immer noch eine absolute
Mehrheit aber haarscharf mit 26 sitzen
und das könnte sich im Laufe des Abends
noch verschieben aber sie könnte
natürlich eine große Koalition bilden
und anführen sie könnte auch ein
rot-grünes Bündnis anführen oder
sozusagen sozial-liberal machen wenn die
FDP drin ist all diese Bündnisse relativ
deutlich mehr als 26 Sitze ein Wort noch
zur Wahlbeteiligung die ist gesunken von
knapp 70% auf jetzt
63%. Dankeschön Mathias für den Moment
in der Regel bekommt der oder die
regierende einen Amtsbonus im Fall von
Tobias hans hat das nicht geklappt er
und die große Gewinnerin des Abends sind
jetzt bei Bettina Schausten in der Runde
und wir dürfen gespannt sein wie sie
dieses Wahlergebnis erklären Bettina
ja Barbara und wir beginnen bei dem
bisherigen Ministerpräsidenten Tobias
Hans das ist ein bitteramt hat der uns
gerade schon gesagt ein desaströses
Ergebnis für die CDU was ist schief
gelaufen Herr Hans und was für
Konsequenzen ziehen Sie auch persönlich
jetzt also zunächst mal ist das in der
Tat eine herbe Niederlage alle Umfragen
haben sich nun bestätigt wir haben nach
über 22,5 Jahren eine
Niederlage erlitten die wir so nicht
erwartet hätten und das schmerzt
natürlich sehr ist eine bittere
Niederlage natürlich auch für meine
Person die ja unmittelbar mit diesem
Wahlkampf auch verbunden waren deswegen
trage ich natürlich auch die
Verantwortung und werde ich auch
persönliche Konsequenzen ziehen aus
diesem Wahlergebnis das ist für mich
selbstverständlich in schwierigen Zeiten
Verantwortung zu übernehmen wir werden
das morgen in den Gremien der Partei die
CDU sah ist eine sehr geschlossene
Partei besprechen miteinander und dann
auch entsprechend darüber informieren
was wenn Sie fragen was es schief
gelaufen das sind natürlich sehr viele
Dinge wenn man so viele Prozentpunkte
einbüßt ist es nicht nur das eine Thema
aber Fakt ist dass es uns in diesem
Wahlkampf nicht gelungen ist die Themen
in den Vordergrund zu stellen und auch
mir persönlich als Spitzenkandidat ist
es nicht gelungen die Menschen zu
überzeugen mit den Zukunftsthemen die
mir wichtig waren das ist alles hinter
das Krisenmanagement zurückgetragen
gekommen in der corona-pandemie und das
mag sicherlich einer der wesentlichen
Gründe sein aber auf der anderen Seite
haben wir gerade eben ja auch gesehen
dass das Parteienspektrum sich im
Saarland völlig verändert hat eine
Linkspartei die von zweistellig auf
unter ferner liefen gefallen ist
Persönlichkeiten haben sich dort
zurückgezogen die wichtig waren für die
Partei die Grünen mit einer sehr
schwierigen Situation und diese
Wählerinnen und Wähler sind
offensichtlich dann eher ins Lager der
SPD gewechselt werden wir unsere Wähler
nicht entsprechend mobilisieren konnten
viel Stoff für die Analyse
ja Frau Rehlinger die Ergebnisse sind
klar und wenn man sich die Zeichnungen
ansieht dann haben Sie freie Wahl im
Prinzip wissen Sie schon was sie machen
jetzt
wir sehen hier vor allem das wir noch
ganz gut beraten sind den Abend
abzuwarten denn es ist ja noch nicht
ganz entschieden wer letztendlich in den
saarländischen Landtag mit einziehen
wird aber ganz unabhängig davon bleibt
es bei dem was ich vorher gesagt habe
Stabilität ist für mich das
entscheidende Kriterium bei dieser
Regierungsbildung dabei spielt immer
Mathematik auch eine Rolle aber nicht
nur sondern es geht auch darum dass man
Vertrauen zueinander hat dass auch den
handelnden Personen etwas zugetraut wird
und da entlang werde auch die
Entscheidungen in Zukunft getroffen
werden wir freuen uns natürlich über
dieses starke Mandat dass wir erhalten
haben und werden natürlich für das Land
das Beste daraus machen ich will ganz
persönlich noch mal ein herzliches Wort
des Dankes auch sagen zumindest für die
Zusammenarbeit bisher wie es weitergehen
wird das werden wir sicherlich sehen ich
glaube es war eine gute Arbeit für
dieses Land und ich sage zu wenn der
Landtag nicht zum Ministerpräsidentin
wird das auch eine gute Arbeit dem
folgen wird
wir schauen zu den Grünen dieser Bäcker
ist die Spitzenkandidatin der
Wiedereinzug in den Landtag ist
geschafft da sieht man ein fröhliches
Gesicht gleichwohl warum konnte doch
nicht mehr Schwung abgegriffen werden
aus Berlin wo ja die Grünen jetzt in der
Regierung sind also zunächst mal warten
wir das Ergebnis ab ob es dann auch
dabei bleibt solltest du bleiben freuen
wir uns natürlich sehr über diesen
Erfolg man kann die Situation hier im
Saarland nicht mit der der Bundespartei
vergleichen wir hatten eine schwierige
Ausgangslage und von daher sind wir froh
über dieses Ergebnis so ist dann auch
dabei bleiben sollte
ja Herr wird die AFD sie sind drin nach
jetzigen Stand sie haben verloren lag
das ein bisschen daran dass sie sich
auch auf keinen Kandidaten einigen
konnten dass ihre Parteien etwas
chaotisches Bild abgegeben hat in
letzter Zeit ja das ist nicht wieder
anzuweisen es ist zum einen kein guter
Tag für kleine Parteien heute gewesen
keine Frage ich denke das liegt auch an
der ukraine-krise Oder rücken die Leute
eher zu den großen Parteien
Sicherheitsgefühl wir haben leider
unsere Themen nicht halten können nicht
spielen können wir das kommt von der
Bundestagswahl mit 10%. waren im Januar
bei 9% bedauerlich aber ich sehe es mit
einem lachenden in einem weinenden Auge
wichtig war bisschen drin in der
gleichen Anzahl an Mandatsträgern von
daher kann ich mit leben
peter war ihnen wird noch gezittert
denke ich mal sie haben dazu gewonnen
aber es ist nicht ganz so wie sie sich
das erhofft hatten richtig naja zunächst
mal wie gesagt wir warten das Ergebnis
noch ab wir sind eigentlich sehr sehr
zuversichtlich dass es noch klappt
andere Hochrechnungen und sehen uns
mittlerweile schon bei 5,1 insofern sind
wir das jetzt zuversichtlich der
Wahlkampf war insofern natürlich sehr
schwierig weil die Frage wer wird
Ministerpräsident oder
Ministerpräsidentin dieses Landes die
entscheidende Frage war wie die den
ganzen Wahlkampf auch überschattet hat
da hatten es alle kleinen Parteien sehr
sehr schwer das sieht man ja auch daran
dass die beiden Parteien die als
Oppositionen jetzt schon im Land hat
waren ebenfalls sehr große
Schwierigkeiten hatten auch die Wähler
zu mobilisieren und umso schwieriger ist
es natürlich für uns als außer
parlamentarischer Opposition die wir
jetzt zehn Jahre waren da die
entsprechende Wahrnehmung einfach zu
bekommen und das erklärt wahrscheinlich
das knappe Ergebnis aber wir sind sehr
zuversichtlich dass es noch klappt zum
Ende des Abends gut es ist alles noch
nicht ganz klar so weit unsere Runde
hier aus im Saarland eines ist klar
nämlich der Machtwechsel und es wird
hier eine neue Ministerpräsidentin geben
Anke Rehlinger zurück nach Mainz
Dankeschön Bettina Schausten und Susanne
Freitag
das Saarland ist flächenmäßig das
kleinste Bundesland mit 750.000
Wahlberechtigten und doch wird das
Ergebnis auch in der Hauptstadt genau
beobachtet denn diese Wahl ist der erste
Stimmungstest für die Ampelkoalition und
sie ist die erste Wahl in der Amtszeit
des neuen CDU-Chefs Friedrich Merz hier
erste Reaktionen aus Berlin
was ist ein wahnsinnig toller Erfolg den
Anke Rehlinger den die SPD dort im
Saarland eingefahren haben nach 23
Jahren schafft man es die CDU-Führung
abzulösen das ist vor allem der Erfolg
von Anke Rehlinger die eine unfassbar
starke Ministerin
Vizeministerpräsidentin war und gefühlt
war sie eigentlich schon die
Ministerpräsidentin und jetzt wird sie
offiziell als noch recht frisch
gewählter Generalsekretär muss ich sagen
ist das natürlich für uns für uns
überzeugte Christdemokraten einen
itraabend ein schmerzhaftes Ergebnis
sind damit nicht zufrieden und als wir
die CDU sind wir im Saarland nicht in
der Situation irgendwelche Forderungen
zu stellen das zeichnet sich ab dass es
wieder eine starke Stimme gibt für
Klimaschutz im Landtag im Saarland dass
es sehr erfreulich und großer Rückenwind
für uns unsere Arbeit auch im Bund wir
hätten uns sicherlich ein zwei Prozent
mehr gewünscht das wird mir dann jetzt
auswerten wir werden mal den Wahlamt
abwarten aber insgesamt bin ich erstmal
zufrieden dass wir wieder als Kor aktiv
in saarländischen Landtag vertreten sind
das Saarland ist kein einfaches Pflaster
für uns das ist jetzt gelingen könnte
dass wir die Chance haben stand jetzt in
den Landtag des Saarlandes einzuziehen
dass wir auch guten
Rückenwind hatten während des Wahlkampfs
das ist ein schon beachtlicher Erfolg
das Ergebnis ist mit Sicherheit
davon geprägt dass die Linke im Saarland
durchaus über die letzten Jahre heftige
Auseinandersetzung geführt hat und es
ist wie es ist man wird keine
zerstrittenen Parteien das Ergebnis
bekommen wir heute in anderen
Deutlichkeit das ist für uns wirklich
bitter und ein Desaster
holen wir uns dazu die Einschätzung von
Theo Koll aus Berlin eine heftige
Klatsche vor allem für die CDU im
Saarland war das wie sehr trifft es die
Bundes-CDU und den neuen Parteichef
Dankeschön nach Berlin Türkei
direkt hier im Anschluss schalten wir
wieder ins zdf-wahlstudio sie können
sich aber auch mit unserer heute App auf
dem Laufenden halten dort ebenfalls
immer die neuesten zahlenentwicklungen
und Reaktionen der Gewinner und
Verlierer
jetzt zum Krieg in der Ukraine da soll
es nach Angaben aus Kiew wieder direkte
Gespräche zwischen den Konfliktparteien
geben und zwar ab morgen in der Türkei
Russland setzt seine massiven Angriffe
unter dessen fort auch Lemberg ganz im
Westen es betroffen Thomas Gonsior und
Michelle Mertes berichten
gigantische Tanks in Flammen fast ein
Sinnbild für den schier nicht enden
wollenden Krieg wenn es erstmal brennt
ist löschen kaum möglich 14 Stunden
dauert der Kampf gegen das Feuer die
Angst ist endgültig angekommen in
Lemberg 80 km vor Polen
die erste Rakete schlug dort ein dann
ein zweiter Einschlag der dritte warf
mich zu Boden
vor dem Krieg hatten wir hier ein Leben
nun nicht mehr wie existieren nur noch
es waren wieder russische Luftangriffe
bestätigt Moskau und zeigt diese Bilder
im Visier angeblich militärdepots ziel
sei die Versorgung abzuschneiden demnach
wurde in Lemberg auch eine militärische
Reparaturwerkstatt angegriffen in Dubno
weitere Treibstofftanks und in rakev ein
Forschungsreaktor der war aber inaktiv
keine Gefahr beteuern ukrainische
Behörden
austragive erreichen uns diese Bilder
die zweitgrößte Stadt der Ukraine in
Ruinen zerstörte Wohnhäuser zeugen von
wochenlangen russischen Vorstößen und
kämpfen Beobachter melden Moskau ziehe
nun einige Truppen Richtung don-bass ab
doch es bleiben Leid und Hilflosigkeit
wäre welches da könnte man wenigstens
Suppe kochen aber weggehen fügt die Frau
hinzu wohin soll ich denn um Angriffe
abzuwehren bittet der Präsident den
Westen um Panzer und Flugzeuge Ukraine
die Ukraine kann russische Raketen nicht
mit Flinten oder Maschinen Gewehren
Abschießen von denen haben wir genug
wie sich schützen in der vormals
anderthalb Millionen Stadt rakiff geht
das jetzt am ehesten in der U-Bahn 100
Zivilisten viele Frauen und Kinder in
einer Stadt unter der Stadt in einem
Land das mal ein ganz normales Leben
kannte
[Musik]
die Rede des US-Präsidenten von gestern
halt nach Russland zeigt sich empört
über beiden Aussage Putin dürfen nicht
an der Macht bleiben aus dem Kreml hieß
es über die Führung in Russland
entscheiden nicht beiden der Präsident
werde vom russischen Volk gewählt beiden
hatte Putin gestern bei seiner Rede in
Warschau als Diktator und Tyrann
bezeichnet er endete mit den Worten um
Gottes Willen dieser Mann kann nicht an
der Macht bleiben
fragen wir Claudia Beetz in Washington
war dieser Satz des US-Präsidenten ein
Versehen
er stand jedenfalls nicht im Manuskript
und überlagert aber nun natürlich was
beiden in dieser Rede eigentlich sagen
wollte er beschrieb ein epochalen Kampf
zwischen Demokratie und Autokratie einen
Kampf um die Freiheit der die Aufgabe
dieser Generation sei und am Ende dieser
sehr intensiven und eindringlichen Rede
hat er sich dann dazu hinreißen lassen
zu sagen Putin können nicht an der Macht
bleiben er hat damit wir das
gelegentlich tut und wofür er hier
gerade zu gerüchtigt ist etwas
ausgesprochen was wohl viele denken aber
was diplomatisch natürlich unglücklich
ist denn Putin kann nun behaupten dass
daraus hervorginge was die USA also
tatsächlich wollten nämlich seinen Sturz
und einen Regimewechsel und deswegen hat
sich das Weiße Haus sehr beeilt dass
wieder einzufangen und auch
Außenminister blinken hat heute noch mal
betont dass es darum dass es beiden
darum gegangen sei dass er nicht die
Macht über die Nachbarländer haben
können
und das Regimewechsel auch weiterhin
nicht das Ziel der US-Politik sei also
ein leichtes zurückrudern in Washington
Dankeschön Claudia Bates
der US-Präsident sagte in seiner Rede
gestern auch dass sich die Welt auf
einen langen Konflikt einstellen müsse
um die künftige internationale Ordnung
ähnlich äußerte sich heute
Bundespräsident Steinmeier auf einem
Solidaritätskonzert der Berliner
Philharmoniker im Schloss Bellevue dort
spielten unter anderem Musiker aus
Belarus Russland und der Ukraine
[Musik]
in einer Videobotschaft schwor
Steinmeier die Deutschen auf härtere
Zeiten ein
trotz aller laufenden diplomatischen
Bemühungen um eine Beendigung des
Krieges unsere Solidarität und unsere
Unterstützung
unsere Standhaftigkeit auch unsere
Bereitschaft zu Einschränkungen
werden noch auf lange Zeit gefordert
sein
und was wenn auch Deutschland bedroht
werden würde kann sich das Land dann
ausreichend verteidigen die Regierung
will ja die Bundeswehr mit 100
Milliarden Euro stärken und denkt dabei
auch über einen deutschlandweiten
raketenschutzschirm nach ein System nach
israelischem Vorbild als Ersatz für das
schon ältere Patchwork Andreas Huppert
berichtet
das flugabwehrraketensystem Patriot ist
so etwas wie der NATO Standard für die
Sicherung gegen feindliche Angriffe aus
der Luft Flugzeuge Raketen oder
Marschflugkörper können bekämpft werden
auch die Bundeswehr vertraut auf dieses
System aus amerikanischer Produktion
doch Patriot ist in die Jahre gekommen
einige Verteidigungsexperten fordern
deshalb eine neue leistungsfähigere
luftabwehrwaffen die aktuelle
Bedrohungslage zeigt ganz klar wir
brauchen ein solches System Deutschland
und Europa ist aktuell gegen eine solche
Bedrohung nicht ausreichend gewappnet
iron Dome eisenkuppel so nennen die
Israelis ihr luftabwehrschutzschild
bestückt mit modernen Raketen
hundertfach erprobt in den letzten
Jahren gegen die Angriffe der hamast
Terroristen iron Dome könnte auch eine
mögliche Variante für Deutschland sein
die Israel die Stellen so etwas her und
deswegen macht es Sinn eben auf diese
verschiedenen unterschiedlichen
Szenarien sich mit nicht nur mit zu
beschäftigen sondern gegebenenfalls auch
umgehen zu kaufen aber das muss eben
alles sehr schnell gehen aber eben auch
sehr Interviews besprochen werden die
Grünen Zweifel ob Israels iron Dome die
passende Lösung ist
das ist nicht auf NATO oder Deutschland
eins zu eins zu übertragen da geht es um
Kurzstreckenraketen da geht es um ein
sehr kleines Territorium und da geht es
auch darum dass man vorher weiß von
welchen Stellen diese Raketen
abgeschossen werden die
Einsatzbereitschaft der Patriots ist
momentan wichtiger denn je im Zuge des
russischen Angriffs auf die Ukraine hat
Deutschland vor einer Woche mehrere
Systeme im nato-auftrag in die Slowakei
verlegt
corona-inflation und jetzt noch der
Ukraine Krieg immer mehr Menschen sind
hierzulande auf die Hilfe der Tafeln
angewiesen dort jedoch werden die Regale
immer leerer Beispiel Ravensburg dort
gibt es seit einigen Wochen etwa 35%
weniger Lebensmittelspenden ähnlich ist
es in Berlin etwa 33% weniger in
Frankfurt gegen die Spenden sogar um
rund 80 Prozent zurück und auch in
Sachsen-Anhalt gibt es Probleme Luisa
hupen
Sammelfahrt für die Tafeln im Harz
Simone Rach und ihre Kollegen fahren die
Supermärkte ab um Spenden abzuholen die
Ausbeute aber ist gering auch mal sonst
jetzt mal jetzt hier drei Kisten am Bond
das sonst sechs sieben Kisten und wenn
man frisches also wenn man jetzt Obst
und Gemüse Joghurt dann das waren ja
palettenweise manchmal das hatte ich
schon krass bemerkbar gemacht die
Supermärkte kaufen sparsamer waren ein
da bleibt für die Tafeln weniger übrig
und auch die privaten Spenden gingen in
den vergangenen Monaten zurück laut
Landesverband in Sachsen-Anhalt um 20
Prozent viele Spenden jetzt für die
Ukraine weil eben halt sehr viel weniger
abgegeben wird oder eben halt auch in
Hilfstransporte geht was auch richtig
ist und die Tafel unterstützt selber
auch die Ukraine und die Anrainerstaaten
aber wir weisen sehr stark darauf hin
dass natürlich die Menschen die in
Deutschland sind und die Hilfe brauchen
auch weiter diese Hilfe bekommen sollen
denn die Zahl der Kundinnen steigt hier
in Bernburg haben sich in den
vergangenen Monaten mehr als 300
Bedürftige neu registriert wegen
steigender Preise sind sie auf die
günstigen Lebensmittel angewiesen und
auch viele Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer
brauchen Starthilfe
das Leben in Europa ist teuer und ich
habe hier noch keine Arbeit deswegen
denke ich dass ich die Hilfe der Tafeln
weiter in Anspruch nehmen werde
die ehrenamtler:innen der Tafeln hoffen
dass ihr Angebot aufrechterhalten können
dafür zählt jede Spende
ja und jetzt kommen wir zum Fußball nach
Sinsheim zur Nationalmannschaft genau
sehr viel Zufriedenheit gestern Abend
denn es war ein erfolgreiches Testspiel
der deutschen Fußballnationalmannschaft
gegen Israel ziel war es so viel wie
möglich auszuprobieren auf dem Weg zur
WM in Katar Tore wurden auch geschossen
zwei von Deutschland heute wurden vor
dem Team Hotel extra Tische aufgebaut zu
groß der Andrang an diesem Sonnentag
Hansi Flick lässt sich von den jüngsten
Erfolgen nicht blenden denn das solide
2:0 durch die Tore der Chelsea Profis
Kai havertz und Timo Werner war kein
wirklicher wm-stresstest ein müheloser
Sieg der aber hätte deutlich höher
ausfallen müssen im großen und ganzen
bin ich zufrieden wir haben wie ich auch
gute Chancen herausgespielt wenn man so
will ist so ein bisschen die Effizienz
die hat gefehlt
und auch da haben wir denke ich mal auch
Luft nach oben die geschonten oder
eingewechselten Spieler wie es sané
werden gegen die Niederlande wieder in
der Startelf stehen genauso wie Manuel
Neuer der heute seinen 36 Geburtstag
feiert
Glückwunsch Formel 1 Pilot Mick
Schumacher fährt heute nicht um Punkte
beim Großen Preis von Saudi Arabien in
jedda Schumacher war gestern im
Qualifying mit mehr als 250 km/h in die
Streckenbegrenzung gekracht großer
Schreckmoment im gesamten haarsteam der
23-Jährige blieb unverletzt seinen Wagen
hingegen ist Schrott in zwei Wochen
sollen Fahrer und Auto dann in
Australien wieder zur Verfügung stehen
und noch zum schiefliegen in Planica
Slowenien Karl Geiger hat wie fast schon
erwartet die große Kristallkugel für den
Gesamtweltcup Sieg verpasst immerhin
wurde er gesamt Zweiter hinter dem
Japaner riojoschi für einen anderen war
der letzte Sprung der Saison auch der
letzte seiner langen erfolgreichen
Karriere
Severin Freund Weltmeister und
Olympiasieger verlässt auf den Schultern
deutscher Teamkollegen die
internationale skisprungwelt einer
seiner potenzielle Nachfolger der
Oberstdorfer Karl Geiger sprang beim
Weltcup Finale im Planitzer mit einem
sehr guten zweiten Versuch auf Platz 16
und gratulierte anschließend dem Japaner
fair und freundschaftlich zum Gewinn des
Gesamtweltcups das letzte Skifliegen
sicherte sich der norwegische
Olympiasieger Marius lindwig vor dem
Japaner Sato und gleich fünf Springern
aus dem Gastgeberland
eine abwechslungsreiche skisprung-saison
21 22 ging heute im slowenischen
Frühling zu Ende
vor 12.000 Zuschauern das dankeschön
ich habe noch die Wetteraussichten für
Sie im Norden teils dichte Wolken aber
nur vereinzelt Regen sonst viel Sonne im
Bergland aber auch einige Quellwolken 9
bis 17 Grad im Norden bis 22 Grad im
Süden am Dienstag im Süden noch mal
freundlich und mit sonst zunehmend
wechselhaft und deutlich kälter viertel
vor zehn ist Christian Sievers dran im
heute-journal ich wünsche Ihnen noch
einen guten Abend bis morgen wenn Sie
mögen hier geht es jetzt wieder live
nach Saarbrücken ins Wahlstudio zu
Bettina Schausten
ja danke schön Barbara willkommen zurück
hier im ZDF Wahlstudio das Saarland hat
gewählt ein kantersee geradezu für die
SPD an Desaster für die CDU an der 5%
Hürde wird noch ein bisschen gerangelt
deshalb zunächst mal eine aktuelle
frische Hochrechnung mit Matthias Honne
so sieht's aus mit Prozenten und
Gewinnen und Verlusten die dann hier
unten drunter stehen die Parteien in der
Reihenfolge wie sie hier im Saarland auf
dem Stimmzettel standen demnach kommt
die CDU auf 28,2 Prozent klare Verluste
SPD stärkste Partei
43,2% sehr starke zu gewinnen die Linke
2,5% nicht mehr im Landtag mit
deutlichen Verlusten die AFD 5,3 Prozent
hat verloren bleibt aber drin die Grünen
5,4% Gewinn dazu und bleiben drin und
die FDP haarscharf unter 5% bei uns
derzeit gewinnt dazu aber es könnte sein
dass es nicht reicht jetzt schauen wir
uns mal an für welche koalitions- und
regierungsoptionen ist eine reichen
würde zwei Szenarios FDP unter Prozent
wie wir sie gerade gesehen haben also
nicht im Landtag dann hat die SPD 27
Sitze diese senkrechte Linie muss man
schaffen das sind die benötigten 26
kommt die FDP noch ins Parlament dann
würde es für eine Alleinregierung der
SPD ganz knapp reichen das kann sich
aber dann im Laufe des Abends auch noch
wieder verschieben für eine große
Koalition natürlich sowieso aber auch
für Rot-Grün und auch wenn die FDP drin
ist für sozial liberal alles deutlich
über den 26 sitzen die man braucht
und bei mir ist jetzt die große Siegerin
des Abends Anke Rehlinger schönen guten
Abend schönen guten Abend so im zweiten
Anlauf hat es in diesem Jahr nun
wirklich geklappt was war anders als vor
fünf Jahren warum jetzt
ja ich denke die Saarländerinnen und
Saarländer haben gesehen dass wir in den
letzten fünf Jahren einfach gute Politik
weitergemacht haben und das durchaus
auch anerkannt wir haben ja auch als
spd-teil in dieser Landesregierung in
wichtigen Politikfeldern Erfolge
erreichen können durch Ansiedlungen aber
auch im Bildungsbereich in Umwelt und
Naturschutz also dort wo wir auch die
Regierungsverantwortung hatten gab es
gute Ergebnisse und wir haben natürlich
auch klar und deutlich gesagt wo wir in
Zukunft hinwollen denn dafür wird man
letztendlich gewählt insofern ein gutes
Paket auch mit vielen tollen
Kandidierenden und ein bisschen
Unterstützung auch aus Berlin das kann
man sicherlich auch sagen insofern ein
gutes Paket bei dem ich sagen würde es
hat letztendlich auch alles gepasst im
Grunde hatten sie den Amtsbonus hier als
Wirtschaftsministerin sie sprechen an
dass sie unterstützung hatten aus Berlin
das war in der Tat so war dieses am Ende
auch ein Stückchen Wahlerfolg von Olaf
Scholz
ich denke schon die Arbeit von Olaf
Scholz und eine Spitze der
Bundesregierung mit den Ministerinnen
und Minister wird zurzeit honoriert die
Menschen in diesem Land sind glaube ich
schon ein Stück weit dankbar dass in
einer solch Krisen behafteten Zeit ein
Kanzler mit Weitsicht und sehr abwägend
und klug die Entscheidungen trifft das
ist das eine aber auch meine Vernetzung
natürlich in die Bundesregierung ist
sicherlich hilfreich für unser kleines
Bundesland denn wir haben große Aufgaben
vor uns mein Ziel ist es diesen Wandel
hin zu einer Stärke auch zu entwickeln
für dieses Land Selbstbewusstsein Stärke
das ist sehr wichtig das geht über
Arbeitsplätze das geht über Wirtschaft
aber das geht dann auch nur wenn man
wirklich sagt im Regierungshandeln
zusammen mit der Bundesregierung werden
die Lösungen erarbeitet werden und das
hat gepasst nun sind sie so stark dass
sie aller Voraussicht nach die absolute
Mehrheit sogar haben und dann allein
regieren müssen muss man vielleicht
sogar sagen ist ihnen das überhaupt
recht
wir warten glaube ich noch mal ein Stück
weit ab ob das so kommt oder auch nicht
wichtig für mich ist tatsächlich dass es
eine zügige Regierungsbildung gibt ob
wir das jetzt alleine zu organisieren
haben oder aber auch noch sondierungs-
und Koalitionsgespräche stattfinden
haben wenn das notwendig ist will ich
gleich noch in der nächsten Woche dazu
einladen denn es sind ja bewegte Zeiten
flüchtlingsmanagement gehört mit
Sicherheit dazu aber auch die Pandemie
sie ist nicht vorbei deshalb ist wichtig
dass jetzt auch noch die
geschäftsführende Regierung gute Arbeit
leistet ein wichtige Botschaft auch an
die Saarländerinnen und Saarländer dass
das funktioniert und nun denn wenn die
Zahlen ist so sind wie sie sind dass wir
eine Alleinregierung bilden können dann
ist das auch möglicherweise ein Zeichen
von Stabilität denn zumindest den Teil
wo man Kompromisse machen muss den
braucht man nicht mehr so stark auch zu
bearbeiten also das heißt aber auch wenn
es reicht und sei es nur ein Sitz
Mehrheit dann werden sie es auch auf
jeden Fall alleine machen oder suchen
Sie sich dann doch einen Partner ich
werde auf jeden Fall eine Regierung
bilden die auf Stabilität und verläss
Krankheit setzt und das ist nicht in
jedem Fall nur ein mathematisches
Ergebnis sondern das ist auch die Frage
wie stabil sind die
Mehrheitsverhältnisse gegebenenfalls
auch solche eine absoluten Mehrheit wie
knapp wie nicht knapp und wie sind die
Partner aufgestellt und da werden wir
jetzt noch mal sehen müssen was passiert
auch bei der CDU wie gesprächsbereit ist
man auch mit diesem Ergebnis wenn denn
dort die Möglichkeiten bestehen oder
Notwendigkeiten bestehen und natürlich
auch die kleinen Parteien müssen ein
Stück weit oder müssten ein Stück weit
auch Beleg dafür liefern dass sie ein
verlässlicher Partner wären das hat auch
etwas mit handelnden Personen zu tun ob
man zutrauen darin haben kann dass Sie
kompetent mit in die Regierung
reinkommen und dass die Partei die
dahinter steht auch wirklich steht erste
Wahl in diesem Jahr 2022 weitere stehen
an und sagen Sie selbst das ist jetzt
auch Signal für Schleswig-Holstein und
für NRW da sollen jetzt die SPD-Kollegen
auch durchziehen na wir sehen zumindest
mal dass die gewonnene Bundestagswahl
aus sozialdemokratischer sich keine
Eintagsfliege war und Olaf Scholz hat ja
gesagt dass Jahrzehnt der
Sozialdemokratie wir befinden uns also
quasi mittendrin ich bin froh dass wir
nach der Bundestagswahl hier in
Saarbrücken die Geschichte ein Stück
weit weitererzählen können und ich gebe
gerne den Staffelstab weiter nach
Schleswig-Holstein und nach
Nordrhein-Westfalen wo ja auch möglich
ist einen Wechsel herbeizuführen und
dann nachher auch schon wieder im Herbst
nach Niedersachsen zu Stefan weil ein
sehr souveränen Ministerpräsidenten also
das könnten gute Wahlen werden aus
sozialdemokratischer Sicht und ich
glaube es ist auch gut für dieses Land
denn wir stehen mit Haltung in
schwierigen Zeiten und das ist etwas
sehr sehr Wichtiges für dieses Land die
schwieriger desto mehr Haltung und dafür
steht ja auch die Sozialdemokratie sind
schon stellvertretende Bundesvorsitzende
werden wir Sie künftig auch mehr auf dem
Berliner Parkett erleben
nun wichtig ist vor allem dass auf dem
Berliner Parkett es möglich ist das
Beste für unser Land rauszuholen
insofern werde ich immer dann auch auf
den Berliner Parkett sein und ich will
natürlich immer dann auch meine Partei
unterstützen wenn ich das tun kann durch
meinen zutun oder durch die Erfahrungen
die ich gesammelt habe aber es geht gar
nicht um Funktionen und Ämter sondern es
geht darum dass man mit dem was man
begleitet auch immer gute Ergebnisse
erzielen kann und am heutigen Tag haben
wir das ja glaube ich ganz gut
hinbekommen Anke Rehlinger die
Wahlsiegerin des heutigen Abends und
künftige Ministerpräsidentin des
Saarlandes vielen Dank herzlichen Dank
und wir können ein Aspekt aus diesem
Gespräch auch noch mal vertiefen nämlich
die Frage des Einflusses der
Bundesparteien der Bundesvorsitzenden
insbesondere und ja es war ja die erste
Landtagswahl für den
cdu-bundesvorsitzenden Friedrich Merz
und wir sehen hier er hat keine Rolle
gespielt oder er spielt keine Rolle für
das Abschneiden der CDU Saarland sagen
gut 60 Prozent bei Olaf Scholz sieht es
nicht viel anders aus 49 Prozent sagen
dass da aber da sagen immer 39 Prozent
er war hilfreich hier im Saarland es
ging das muss man unterm Strich klar
sagen ganz klar um Themen und Personen
im Saarland danke Matthias ja die
Bundesspitze der CDU hat sich recht rar
gemacht im Wahlkampf 4 im Saarland
Tobias Hans ist der ballverlehrer des
heutigen Abends und er hat sich vor
wenigen Minuten seiner Partei gestellt
ich weiß wenn man solche
Zahlen sieht er will mal weg will man
eigentlich am liebsten das Weite suchen
den Kopf in Sand stecken ich ins Bett
legen aber das liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde ist nicht unsere CDU sagt die
CDU sagt kämpft und sie kämpft auch dann
wenn man verloren hat und deswegen liebe
Freundinnen Freunde ist für mich klar
ich übernehme die Verantwortung für
dieses Wahlergebnis denn das
Wahlergebnis ist mit meiner Person
verbunden als Spitzenkandidat
und deswegen werde ich auch persönliche
Konsequenzen mit dem Vorstand mit der
Fraktion am morgigen Tag beraten und ich
bin sicher wir werden gemeinsam so wie
wir als CDU sah immer gekämpft haben
auch in diesen schweren Stunden dieser
Zäsur der Machtverlust nach 22,5 Jahren
gemeinsam gute Lösungen finden damit wir
im Sinne unserer Partei und auch im
Sinne dieses Saarlandes das eine starke
CDU braucht egal in welcher Rolle auch
wieder nach vorne blicken können dazu
werde ich meinen Beitrag leisten mit der
Übernahme dieser Verantwortung das ist
mir eine Ehre und liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde es war mir eine Ehre diesem Land
gedient zu haben als Ministerpräsident
und eine Ehre euch als
Parteivorsitzender gedient zu haben ich
bedanke mich für all eure Unterstützung
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
Applaus noch mal in der Niederlage für
Tobias Hans der persönliche Konsequenzen
nach diesem Wahl Desaster ankündigt das
klingt nach einem Rücktritt am morgigen
Tag so die Wahl im kleinsten deutschen
Flächenland endet mit einem Triumph für
die spd-auftakt in ein Wahljahr bei dem
sich im Mai weitere CDU
Ministerpräsidenten zur Wahl stellen und
eine Wahl die durch größere Themen wie
die corona-pandemie den Krieg in der
Ukraine nicht entschieden aber doch
überschattet wurde die Politik ist in
besonderer Weise gefordert in diesen
Zeiten und darum wird es nun sicher auch
gehen in der Berliner Runde in unserem
Hauptstadtstudio die die Wahlergebnisse
aber auch die größeren Herausforderungen
dieser Tage diskutieren wird Theo Koll
hat seine Gäste versammelt bei sich und
ich gebe jetzt direkt ab nach Berlin in
einer halben Stunde melden wir uns hier
zurück Theo bitte
vielen Dank Bettina und damit guten
Abend und herzlich Willkommen zu
Berliner Runde das Saarland hat so klein
wie es ist schon für ganze Wahljahre den
Ton gesetzt denn von hier gehen dann
Trends für alle folgenden Wahlen des
Jahres aus 2017 jedenfalls war das so
damals für die CDU die sah Wahl ist
nicht nur die erste von vier
Landtagswahlen in diesem Jahr es ist
auch die erste Wahl nach dem Antritt der
Ampelkoalition in Berlin und es ist die
erste Bewährungsprobe einer neuen
CDU-Spitze das wollen wir in kompakten
30 Minuten Berliner Runde ausloten mit
vielen neuen Köpfen in neuen Funktionen
wir begrüßen Emily Büning politische
Geschäftsführerin der Grünen Bernd
Baumann erster parlamentarischer
Geschäftsführer der AFD Mario Chaya
Generalsekretär der CDU wie Jeannine
designierter Generalsekretär der FDP
Kevin Kühnert Generalsekretär der SPD
Stefan Mayer Generalsekretär der CSU und
Jörg Schindler Bundesgeschäftsführer der
Linken
Kevin Kühnert beginnen wir auf der auf
der sonnigen Seite diese dieser Wahl die
Spitzenkandidatin ihrer Partei Frau
Rehlinger hat ja
persönlichkeitswerte die weit vor dem
Amtsinhaber lagen was ja sehr
ungewöhnlich ist ist es vor allem oder
ausschließlich ihr Wahlerfolg oder
reklamieren Sie für den Bund auch etwas
es ist vor allem der Wahlerfolg der
Saar-SPD und von Anke Rehlinger die
Zahlen dort sprechen für sich aber es
hat natürlich auch Unterstützung gegeben
das hat sie selber heute abend betont
nicht nur dadurch dass viele von uns vor
Ort waren der Kanzler war dort die
Parteispitze war dort sondern man nimmt
die SPD ich glaube das kann man schon
sagen seit einiger Zeit wieder als eine
klarorientierte geschlossene sortierte
Partei war bei uns macht man nicht mehr
geht im Wahlkampf gegeneinander wie das
in der Vergangenheit vielleicht auch mal
der Fall war sondern wir stehen einander
bei und dann sind solche Erfolge auch
möglich aber sie weisen ja zu Recht auf
etwas Sinn es ist schon auch eine
Seltenheit dass eine vormalige Junior
Partnerin so eine Wahl so deutlich
entscheidet das wird jetzt seit fünf
Jahren das erste Mal sein dass an der
Spitze eines Bundeslandes in Deutschland
ein Farbwechsel stattfindet und insofern
ist das ein besonderer Wahlabend und
keine Alltäglichkeit haben sich bei
Oskar Lafont nein dafür fehlt mir auch
die Telefonnummer um mich zu bedanken
und noch mal das ist schon auch eigene
Stärke mit der wir das geschafft haben
wir freuen uns über das große Vertrauen
auch von denjenigen die uns bei den
letzten Mal im Saarland nicht gewählt
haben das ist ja offensichtlich bei
diesem zugewinnen so dass da einige auch
den Weg wieder zurück zu ihrer SPD
gefunden haben aber das ist nicht nur
eine Ablehnung von anderen Parteien
sondern vor allem eben auch eine
Zustimmung zur sah SPD und der geht
heute Abend der Glückwunsch sie sind neu
in ihrem Amt eine nicht gerade
freundliche Begrüßung durch dieses
Wahlergebnis nach 23 Jahren verliert die
Union
den ministerpräsidentenposten nach
heftigem Absturz wie werden sie das
morgen in aller Offenheit die Partei
Gremien erklären
ja zunächst ist das kein schöner Abend
für die Union wir haben gemeinsam
gekämpft und wir kämpfen gemeinsam wir
verlieren gemeinsam deswegen sagen wir
zunächst danke allen die dort diesen
Wahlkampf geführt haben und der
schwierigen Ausgangsvoraussetzungen und
es ist deutlich nicht gelungen dass wir
die Themen des Saarlands dort verankern
und zum Ausdruck bringen wofür stehen
wir im Saarland und das ist ja das was
wir gerade in Berlin in ganz anderer Art
und Weise tun dass wir auch deutlich
machen wo sind wir wichtiger Partner
beispielsweise bei der Stärkung der
Bundeswehr bei einem bei den schwierigen
Situationen rund um die Energiepreise
dass wir da als wichtiger Partner auch
mit klaren Positionen wahrgenommen
werden und das ist im Saarland so nicht
gelungen also Tobias hans hat sicher
Fehler gemacht wir das berühmte Video
dass er in einer Tankstelle aufgenommen
hat wir können es ja mal ganz kurz noch
mal einspielen vielleicht hat sie hier
Zuschauer gesehen an diesen gestiegenen
Energiekosten und deswegen muss eine
spritpreisbremse her das trifft jetzt
nicht nur Geringverdiener sondern das
trifft wirklich die vielen fleißigen
Leute die tanken müssen die ihre also er
hat sich damit sehr viel Kritik
eingefangen
heute meinte er aber die Saat CDU habe
gekämpft wie eine Eins und auch seine
Frau habe ihn unterstützt die Bundes-CDU
wurde da nicht erwähnt sie haben eben
reklamiert dass man gemeinsam gekämpft
habe dass klingt bei ihm anders also um
das deutlich zu sagen die Unterstützung
aus dem adenauerhaus hat es in enormer
Weise ergeben daran hat es sicherlich
nicht gemangelt in der Bundesvorsitzende
war einmal dort der Bundesvorsitzende
war einige Male im Saarland wir haben
eine bundesvorstandsklausur dort gemacht
wir waren mit dem Präsidium unterwegs
auch im Saarland daran hat es sicherlich
gelegen es ist so wie Kevin kühnerdes
gesagt hat es waren vor allem die Themen
des Saarlands die im Mittelpunkt bei den
Gesprächen stand ich habe das an den
Haustüren an den ich auch im Saarland
unterwegs war deutlich verspürt und Anke
Rehlinger man muss ihr Respekt sein ist
es gelungen diese wirtschaftspolitischen
Themen in dieser Koalition auf sich zu
vereinen was einem Juniorpartner in der
Vergangenheit eher nicht gelungen ist
aus dieser Horner herauszukommen das ist
ihr gelungen und sie hat die
wirtschaftspolitische Kompetenz stärker
bewiesen als uns das im Saarland
gelungen nochmal also die allgemeine
Wahrnehmung war dass die SPD-Spitze sehr
viel deutlicher vor Ort war der
Bundeskanzler war da die beiden
Parteivorsitzenden waren da das war die
Wahrnehmung auch im Saarland sie würden
aber keinerlei Verantwortung übernehmen
auf Bundesseite dass sie zu wenig
unterstützt haben ja wie gesagt also ich
will diese mehr nicht weitertreiben wir
haben eine große Unterstützung gegeben
es waren saarländische Themen die im
Mittelpunkt standen wir waren einige
Male vor Ort wir haben viel
Unterstützung gegeben es ging um
saarländische Themen und um die
kompetenzfragen die da eine Rolle
spielen die Briefwahl war bereits wenige
Wochen nachdem wir im Amt waren begonnen
so dass auch ein Großteil derer schon
gewählt hat die Ausgangsbedingungen
waren im Saarland andere als sie im Bund
oder in anderen Bundesländern sind Herr
Schindler die das Saarland war bisher ja
ihre westdeutsche Hochburg muss man
sagen Oskar Lafontaine hat er 2009 über
Prozent geholt 21,3% selbst bei der
letzten Wahl 2017 hatten sie noch in
zweistelliges Ergebnis und jetzt sieht
es nach zweieinhalb Prozent aus der
Partei Promi Oskar Lafontaine hat ja
seinen Parteiaustritt kurz vor der Wahl
begründet normal und Geringverdiener
oder auch Rentner fühlen sich von der
Partei nicht mehr vertreten gibt ihm das
Wahlergebnis jetzt recht nein auf keinen
Fall aber ich will zunächst mal sagen
dass für uns das in schwarzer Tag ist
ein ganz bittere Niederlage die wir die
wir hier erleiden mussten das ist völlig
klar und ich sie haben es ja
angesprochen der Landesverband ist seit
Jahren von Konflikten geprägt gewesen
die saarländischen Themen haben da eine
Rolle gespielt aber insbesondere ein
gewisses Spezifikum im Saarland was ja
alle Parteien betrifft jedenfalls hat
das in unserem Landesverband natürlich
auch seit Jahren diese Querelen gegeben
und sie haben es angesprochen zehn Tage
vor der Wahl auszutreten aus unserer
Partei und zur aufzurufen die Linke
nicht zu wählen hat uns natürlich auch
noch mal massiv geschadet da muss man
gar nicht drumherum reden das ist
richtig was wir jetzt tun müssen ist die
Partei neu aufstellen wir sind nicht
sehr Landtag Vertrieb im Saarland in
welchem Bundestag sind sie ja auch im
Saarland direkt im Saarland sind wir
jetzt nicht mehr im Landtag vertreten
und das heißt dass wir die Partei
diejenigen die dort aktiv sind das eine
ganze Menge wir haben dort über 1.600
Mitglieder die vor allen Dingen in
Gemeinden in Gemeinderäten aber auch in
Gewerkschaften und ähnlichen aktiv sind
dass wir die sammeln und da die Partei
wieder neu aufstellen das ist jetzt
notwendig das müssen wir tun das ist
eine schwierige Aufgabe sie sagen das
aber das müssen wir tun denn eins ist
doch klar das Saarland braucht eine
soziale Opposition die wird jetzt außer
parlamentarisch sein aber da müssen wir
durch und das wird nicht zu kurz
gesprungen ich meine sie sind in
Bundestag ja auch nur wegen der
Direktmandate gekommen wenn sie sagen
wir müssen uns neu aufstellen im
Saarland reicht das
es ist so dass wir im Bund die soziale
Opposition sind ich will das noch mal
anhand von einem Beispiel benennen
gerade beim entlang sie wollen ja
Beispiele gerade beim Entlastungspaket
sind ja jetzt von der Ampelkoalition die
Rentnerin und Rentner in überwiegende
Anzahl mal schlicht vergessen worden und
ich finde da ist es notwendig dass wir
als soziale Opposition im Bund wirken
und das tun wir und die umfragen sagen
ja auch dass wir zumindest bei Gerhard
Trabert als Alternative zum
Bundespräsidenten durchaus Umfragen um
die 7% hatten das heißt eine konkrete
klare soziale Opposition wird auch
Zustimmung finden da sind wir dran wir
machen auch Fehler ganz klar aber ich
bin da fest davon überzeugt wenn wir
diesen Kurs der sozialen
Interessenvertretung beibehalten dann
werden wir auch wieder gewählt werden
also das heißt ich fasse zusammen sie
sehen also personell und in der in der
programmatischen Aufstellung jetzt keine
veränderungsnotwendigkeit also sie sehen
doch dass dieses Wahlergebnis so wie es
in dieser Dramatik für uns war dieses
Wahlergebnis ist ein Ausdruck der tief
greifenden und seit Jahren laufenden
Konflikte im Landesverband Saar dort
werden wir auch als Bundespartei in
Zukunft eine aktive Rolle spielen wir
werden die Partei dort neu aufstellen
müssen das ist völlig klar und das wird
auch bedeuten dass wir als Bundespartei
dort aktiv eingreifen damit die Partei
wieder handlungsfähig wird denn das war
sie in letzter Zeit nicht so richtig die
Genossen und genossen vor Ort haben
durchaus ein engagierten Wahlkampf
gemacht aber in so einer Situation
lassen sich diese Wahlergebnisse dann
auch nicht mehr vermeiden Herr Baumann
heftig zerstritten zu sein ist ja nichts
exklusives linkes sondern sie kennen das
aus ihrem Landesverband im Saarland auch
ihre schon eingereichte Landesliste
wurde wieder zurückgenommen gegen zwei
Kandidaten laufen Ausschlussverfahren
ihr saarländischer Generalsekretär
Melling der abgesägte Spitzenkandidat
sagte über den eigenen Verein es geht
nicht um Politik es geht um Geld und
Posten stärker kann man Wähler
eigentlich nicht abschrecken oder ach
das hat glaube ich Lafontaine jetzt
gerade über die linke auch gesagt und
die gleichen Vorwürfe gibt es eine
täuschend Parteimitgliedern auch bei
anderen Parteien man kann jetzt an den
Wahlergebnissen sehen wir sind jetzt
relativ sicher drin und je nachdem wie
der Abend dass wie sich das ergibt ist
wenn ich die neuesten Zahlen sehe können
wir sogar noch stärkste
Oppositionspartei werden im Saarland ob
das von vornherein so zu erwarten war
weiß ich nicht wenn man guckt wie
beispielsweise der Verfassungsschutz aus
unserer Sicht missbraucht wurde gegen
uns es wissen einfach draußen im Land
noch viel zu wenig Menschen dass der
Verfassungsschutz keine neutrale
unabhängige Organisation und Verwaltung
ist wie das wie der Bundesrechnungshof
oder der das Bundesverfassungsgericht
sondern eine abhäng Behörde der
Innenminister die das sozusagen
missbrauchen können
und das mag sozusagen den ein oder
anderen Wähler draußen der weiß das noch
nicht der Verfassungsschutz macht
unabhängige Arbeit ist gerade von den
Gerichten auch bestätigt worden die
Gerichts also da gibt es ja
Berufungsverfahren das ist noch nicht
rechtsgültig die ganze Sache es gibt auf
jeden Fall in allen westlichen Ländern
Parteien wie die AFD gegen den Links
grünen Mainstream wie man das bezeichnen
will in allen Ländern keines der
westlichen Länder keine westliche
Demokratie beobachtet eine Partei durch
den Inlandsgeheimdienst die Opposition
wie das in Deutschland passiert das ist
schon Unikum und dafür muss ich sagen
haben sich unsere Wahlkämpfer ganz
tapfer geschlagen und trotzdem haben sie
Wähler verloren sowohl im Vergleich zu
2017 als auch im Vergleich zu ihrem
bundesergebnis hat das Wähler
abgeschreckt nachher das macht ja genau
daran gelegen haben die Innenminister
haben den Durchgriff auf den
Verfassungsschutz ist eine abhängige
Behörde das geht dann durch social
Medien hier wird irgendwas beobachtet
das ist für uns zutiefst missbräuchlich
ich sage nochmal allen westlichen Länder
gibt es das nicht bei ähnlichen Parteien
aber wie gesagt
das müssen wir einfach noch aufklären
dass das mehr Leute wissen dass das
keine selbstständige Behörde ist die
neutral ermittelt
Frau Büning auch ihre Partei ist im
Saarland heftig zerstritten das ist bei
den kleinen Parteien offensichtlich
einen Merkmal im Saarland zur letzten
Bundestagswahl haben sie nicht mal eine
Landesliste aufstellen können wieso hat
die Berliner Parteispitze da nicht
ausreichend durchgegriffen
also wenn sich das Wahlergebnis so
bestätigt wie es sich gerade abzeichnet
bin ich erstmal sehr froh dass wir mit
den Grünen im Saarland wieder Kompetenz
für Klimaschutz erneuerbare Energien und
zukunftsfähige Arbeitsplätze im Landtag
vertreten haben natürlich ist das
Saarland ein besonderes Bundesland und
für uns Grüne ist das auch ein
schwieriges Bundesland gewesen auch
schon in den letzten Jahren da lässt
sich nichts machen das sagt der Bund so
wir haben ja wenn wir jetzt den
Wiedereinzug erfolgreich schaffen da
einen wichtigen Schritt zur
Neuaufstellung geschafft da bin ich sehr
zuversichtlich wenn das sich jetzt so
bestätigt Lisa Becker unsere
Spitzenkandidatin im Saarland und die
Wahlkämpferinnen und Wahlkämpfer der
Grünen im Saarland haben da wirklich
einen guten Job gemacht wir haben das
auch von bundesweite unterstützt unsere
Bundesvorsitzenden waren auch beide im
Saarland und haben dort
Wahlkampfauftritte gehabt ich bin sehr
zuversichtlich dass wir uns als Grüne im
Saarland jetzt neu aufstellen können wir
den ersten richtigen Schritt darin
geschafft haben und damit im Saarland
auch wieder als Grüne im Landtag die
Politik machen können und vor allen
Dingen auch dann wieder in 16
Landesparlamenten vertreten sind das für
uns im Bund natürlich auch ein wichtiges
Zeichen sie haben in ihrer Bewerbung für
das Amt der Geschäftsführerin
geschrieben wir brauchen die grüne
Stärke in den Ländern jetzt sind sie
zwar drin aber stark ja nicht
für uns ist es ein wichtigen Schritt
überhaupt wieder in den Landtag
einzuziehen im Saarland wir hatten noch
nie mehr als 5,9 Prozent im Saarland und
da jetzt wieder einzuziehen in allen
Landesparlamenten vertreten zu sein das
ist für uns wichtig und ein guter
Schritt und ich glaube Klimaschutz
erneuerbare Energien und
zukunftsfähige Arbeitsplätze da im
Landtag auch im Saarland vertreten zu
haben und wieder inhaltliche Politik im
Saarland auch machen zu können als grüne
ist für uns gut und wichtig schauen wir
auf die FDP die
Bund regieren sie mit und setzen sich
hier auf wie man sehen kann
beispielsweise im Infektionsschutzgesetz
ordentlich durch in dieser Koalition im
Saarland waren sie jetzt seit zehn
Jahren nicht mehr im Landtag was ist
denn da anders und was läuft schief also
zunächst einmal ob Akteure aus der
Politik oder Kommentatoren politischer
Natur alle haben glaube ich heute Abend
und in den Tagen davor ganz deutlich
gesagt dass das eine besondere
Landtagswahl ist im Saarland
landesspezifische Themen und landespolit
die Köpfe haben diese Wahl entschieden
ich persönlich habe im Saarland bei den
Freunden der uns bei meiner Partei ein
sehr engagierten Wahlkampf erlebt aber
nicht desto trotz es ist eine
landespolitische Wahl und eine
landespolitische Entscheidung die
Situation auf Bundesebene stellt sich
derzeit anders da die FDP ist ja wie Sie
wissen derzeit bei allen Umfragen auf
Bundesebene stabil über 9 Prozent sogar
teilweise über 10%. das heißt das ist
eine völlig andere Situation und sie
haben völlig recht um Ihre Frage auch
sehr konkret zu beantworten wir waren
zwei Wahlperioden nicht mehr im Landtag
vertreten ich kann mich noch daran
erinnern aber nicht das so trotz der
Abend ist lang und ich bin optimistisch
dass es dieses Mal klappt also
mit verschraubt ich sie sind die Bundes
vertreten die Bundespartei sind sie so
wenig einflussreich in den
Landesverbänden dass sie so wenig
verändern können über eine so lange Zeit
nein das hat damit nicht zu tun und
jeder der schon mal an einem Wahlkampf
genommen hat weiß genau dass natürlich
die bundespolitische Ebene also die
aktuelle politische Lage auf Bundesebene
immer eine Rolle spielt aber
letztendlich vor Ort das ist übrigens
auch bei den anderen Landtagswahlen die
kommen werden oder die vorher
stattgefunden werden am Ende des Tages
sind das die landespolitische
Besonderheiten die eine Wahl entscheiden
was sind die Themen die in dem
jeweiligen Bundesland existieren und wer
sind die Köpfe und auch und sagen Sie
mal ganz kurz woran es gelegen hat nein
wir wissen ja wie eine Analyse dieser
Wahl wird ja noch kommen ich glaube noch
sind wir in einem Prozess drin wir
können das ja noch nicht abschließend
bewerten was für ein Ergebnis wir heute
abend erreicht haben wie gesagt die
Analyse wird kommen aber im Kern sie
haben im Grunde genommen mit Ihrer Frage
und ja auch schon die Antwort gegeben
zwei Wahlperioden außer parlamentarisch
zu arbeiten im Saarland das ist
außerordentlich schwer ohne die
notwendige Infrastruktur aber das nicht
das trotz ich habe einen sehr guten
Wahlkampf der FDP gesehen und ich bin
optimistisch dass das Gut wird Herr
Meier Tobias Hans und ihr
Ministerpräsident waren ja lange Zeit
seit an Seite es hieß auch mal Team
Vorsicht mal teamöffnungen Hans wurde
dafür im Wahlkampf jetzt als wankelmütig
kritisiert wie viel Warnung ist ihnen
das für die eigene Landtagswahl in
Bayern die kommt ja lieber Herr Kollege
schon mehrmals erwähnt worden dass die
landesthemen hier schon sehr dominierend
und ausschlaggebend waren was das
Wahlergebnis anbelangt es war eine
Landtagswahl und so soll es ja auch sein
dass dann entsprechend auch die
landtagsthemen wie die Zukunft die
wirtschaftliche Zukunftsfähigkeit die
Sicherung der Arbeitsplätze das
Bildungssystem auch wahlentscheidend
waren ich kann dabei leider überhaupt
keinen Bundestrend ablesen und andersrum
was auch dieses Wahlergebnis hier
eindeutig zeigt die Ampel hat nicht
gewirkt die Ampelkoalition hat ihren
Parteien mit Ausnahme der SPD keinen
Rückenwind verliehen und das kann ich
mir das doch relativ schwache Ergebnis
sowohl der FDP als auch der Grünen nicht
sein also das war eine SPD nehmen sie
raus aus dieser Analyse die SPD war
natürlich die Gewinnerin davon dass sich
das linke Lager sehr stark wieder
kohärent gezeigt hat und sehr stark
hinter der SPD gezeigt hat es war eine
Landtagswahl und hier irgendwelche
Rückschlüsse zu ziehen was andere Länder
anbelangt bzw den Bund halte ich für
sehr
aber ich habe auch das Verhältnis der
beiden der beiden Ministerpräsidenten
geschaut Tobias hans war ja in der
Entscheidung über die Kandidatenfrage
beispielsweise auch jemand der relativ
deutlich vernehmbar indirekt Markus
Söder unterstützt hat gab es eigentlich
irgendwelche Wahlkampfunterstützung
jetzt als Dankeschön von ihrem
Ministerpräsidenten außerdem Tweet heute
wir haben natürlich die Wahlkämpfer vor
Ort auch mit unterstützt wir haben
natürlich auch gesehen dass hart
gekämpft wurde dass die CDU sah tapfer
und sehr einig auch gekämpft hat aber es
war natürlich auch eine schwierige
mengenlage was die kompetenzwerte
anbelangt was die persönlichkeitswerte
der unterschiedlichen Spitzenkandidaten
anbelangt und weil sie auf das
Verhältnis zu Markus Söder ansprechen es
gab ja auch in vielen anderen
cdu-landesverbänden Verbänden
Unterstützung für Markus Söder im
letzten Jahr aber ich denke wir sollten
jetzt die Vergangenheit ruhen lassen und
nach vorne blicken was aus meiner Sicht
auch klar ist dass sich die CDU und die
CSU jetzt wieder geschlossen
zusammengefunden haben und gerade auch
die Umfragewerte der CDU in
Nordrhein-Westfalen oder auch in
Schleswig-Holstein zeigen ja sehr wohl
dass es auch ganz andere Trends gibt
also hier einen Trend für andere Länder
und für andere
ministerpräsidentenkandidaten abzuleiten
halte ich wirklich für verfehlt
auf das Thema Koalition also wenn es die
Möglichkeit eine absoluten Mehrheit gibt
wäre dann ihre Empfehlung in Richtung
sah Alleinregierung oder würden Sie für
mögliche Koalitionen mit den Grünen oder
vielleicht sogar eine Ampel wenn das
möglich ist ohne dass es nötig wäre
jetzt da vollkommene Zurückhaltung von
Ihnen oder Empfehlungen
ich verspreche Ihnen sofort Ihre Frage
zu beantworten will aber schon noch mein
Satz sagen weil jetzt haben wir 20
Minuten damit verbracht festzuhalten
dass das heute abend eine Landtagswahl
gewesen ist das haben jetzt glaube ich
alle verstanden aber was heißt denn das
eigentlich eine Landtagswahl ist ja
trotzdem wichtig da geht es um eine
Million Menschen die dort leben wo es um
deren bildungsverkehrs Arbeitsmarkt und
Wirtschaftspolitik gegangen ist es geht
um wichtige Stimmen im Bundesrat und
damit auch um Bundespolitik und auch
wenn zu Recht gesagt wird ja die Themen
des Landes standen weit vorne muss man
ja mal schauen welche waren das das
waren insbesondere Industrie und
Arbeitsplätze das Saarland ist ein
Industrieland da geht es um die Frage ob
wir in Zukunft noch Stahlproduktion in
Deutschland haben werden es eben mit der
SPD heute auch eine Partei gewählt
worden die sich unumwunden dazu bekannt
hat dass wir Industriestandort sind das
ist Industriearbeitsplätze gibt und zwar
auch im regenerativen Zeitalter mit
grünem Stahl und vielem andere mehr
darüber hat der Bundeskanzler beim
Besuch vor Ort gesprochen und insofern
sollten wir schon auch ein paar
inhaltliche Erkenntnisse aus diesem Tag
ziehen und mit dem Wahlergebnis was wir
da heute bekommen haben kann es wir
werden und abwarten müssen sein dass wir
auch alleine regieren können das wird
sie wenig wundern das freut dann ein
Sozialdemokraten und eine
Sozialdemokratin und wenn das wäre dann
auch ihre Empfehlung sagt naja am
grillinger hat gesagt sie will eine
stabile und verlässliche Regierung
führen und sie werden es mir nachsehen
wenn man die Möglichkeit hat eine
Regierung nur mit Sozialdemokratinnen
und Sozialdemokraten zu wählen dann
werde ich und vermutlich alle in meiner
Partei das für eine stabile Regierung
halten aber wir warten jetzt mal ab wie
das amtliche Endergebnis ist die
Landesregierung die werden vor Ort
entschieden und das ist auch gut so das
Saarland ist ein sehr besonderes
Bundesland das sieht man auch an dem
Ergebnis heute in den politischen
Stimmungen vor Ort und ich glaube das
können wir jetzt nicht einfach aus
Berlin sagen wie die das vor Ort zu
organisieren haben das wissen die schon
ganz gut selbst
die beiden die in einer groko verbunden
waren
CDU und SPD sind ja relativ freundlich
miteinander umgegangen im Saarland
auf Bundesebene haben Sie jetzt die
Situation ich sage mal in Kriegszeiten
als Opposition möglicherweise ja auch
nicht so kritisch mit der Regierung
umgehen zu können wie das in
Wahlkämpfen eigentlich angemessen wäre
oder
ja wir sind in einer außergewöhnlichen
Situation das haben sie beschrieben der
Bundeskanzler ist ja auf uns zugekommen
und möchte die Investitionen die
Bundeswehr in das Grundgesetz aufnehmen
das tut er ja auch weil er weiß dass er
seinen eigenen Sozialdemokraten nicht
allzu sehr vertrauen kann und weil er
weiß dass es wichtig ist dass diese
Investition auch noch getätigt wird wenn
er nicht mehr Bundeskanzler ist und
jedenfall andere bei den bei den Grünen
junge grüne haben ja gesagt davon könnte
man 10.000 Tonnen Cannabis bestellen
oder 20 Milliarden Hamster die Frau
Ministerin werbock hat gesagt wir
streichen das Thema Streitkräfte gleich
ganz aus dem Gesetz das zeigt ja man
braucht uns als Faktor für Stabilität im
Land aber dieser gleichzeitig ein und
dieser Verantwortung werden wir momentan
auch gerecht mit all der notwendigen
Zurückhaltung in solchen Zeiten nicht
auf das Kleinklein von parteipolitischen
Zeit zurückzufallen sondern das große
Ganze zu sehen wenn grundsätzliche
Fehler passieren dann auch darauf
hinzuweisen und zu sagen da und da
braucht man Veränderung beispielsweise
bei den gestiegenden Energiepreisen wir
haben die Vorschläge gemacht zur
EEG-Umlage man die Regierung ist dann in
kleinen Schritten gefolgt aber es sind
ein paar Dinge angesprochen waren heute
beispielsweise bei der Entlastung der
Rentner da bleibt die Regierung hinter
vielem zurück was wir uns da vorstellen
was leiten sie aus dieser Rolle in der
sie jetzt sind der gesteigerten
Verantwortung für die kommenden
Wahlkämpfe ab
bleibt das so wir haben in Berlin eine
Rolle dass wir derzeitig sehr
verantwortungsbewusst wie ohnehin in der
Opposition zu agieren haben aber in
solchen Zeiten noch mal besonders darauf
zu achten dass man da wo es möglich ist
Gemeinsamkeiten mit der Regierung hat
und eine enge Konsultation und da muss
ich sagen findet die zwischen
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz und Friedrich
Merz auch derzeitig sehr
verantwortungsbewusst statt in dem
Wissen darum dass es darum geht dass wir
einheitlich da auftreten und nicht zu
sehr aufs kleinen achten in
Schleswig-Holstein Nordrhein-Westfalen
geht es um starke lokale Themen da
werden wir auch unsere Position zum
Ausdruck bringen das ist das Thema der
wirtschaftspolitischen Kompetenz
angesprochen worden sein besonderer
Umstand dass einer Wirtschaftsministerin
in der großen Koalition gelungen ist auf
diese Themen hinzuweisen die unter der
Führung von Tobias Hans im Saarland
vorangebracht wurden und wir haben im
Schleswig-Holstein und in
Nordrhein-Westfalen andere
Ausgangsbedingungen aber wir werden dort
soweit es möglich ist auch unterstützen
Frau Büning das Saarland ist ein
pendlerland und viele leiden unter den
hohen
Energiepreisen offenbar hat aber auch
viele Saarländer das von ihnen ja
eingesetzte energieentlastungspaket
nicht so überzeugend gewirkt dass sie
sie die Grünen gewählt hätten oder
ich würde sagen es wurde schon oft
angesprochen dass Saarland ist ein
besonderes Land und ich glaube der
Faktor der Landespolitik war sehr hoch
es war eine Personenwahl zwischen Anke
und Tobias Hans ich glaube das
Entlastungspaket war ein sehr wichtiges
Zeichen für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
in Deutschland ich bin sehr froh dass
wir das in der Koalition geschafft haben
das zu einen ich glaube das Zeichen dass
wir 300 Euro
energiegeld eine pauschale an alle
Bürgerinnen und Bürger auszahlen und um
einmal darauf Anzug einzugehen dass wir
die Rentnerinnen und Rentner vergessen
hätten die Rentnerinnen und Rentner
erhalten aufgrund der Vereinigung
unserer Koalition eine erhebliche
Rentensteigerung von über sechs Prozent
ich glaube es ist ein wichtiges Zeichen
für die Rentnerinnen und Rentner zudem
glaube ich auch dass wir ja auch für die
Autofahrerinnen und Autofahrer im
Saarland haben wir ja auch drei Monate
energiesteuersenkung vereinbart und auch
die ÖPNV
Senkung für drei Monate ich glaube das
ist sind wichtige Entlastung für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in Deutschland
und ich bin sehr froh darüber dass wir
das in der Koalition geschafft haben und
ich glaube eben dass die Bundeswehr
bundespolitische Einfluss im Saarland
eben sehr
grenzt war man sieht ja im Bundestrend
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger in
Deutschland sind durchaus sehr zufrieden
mit dem was grüne in der Regierung
leisten gerade
Haken also weil das was an
einer Frage verbinden
wir erleben ja dass diese Krisen in
denen wir jetzt in diese großen Krisen
ganz besondere Dinge Highlighten und
klarer machen sie haben in ihrer Partei
jetzt gerade erlebt dass Hans Modrow im
Ältestenrat der Partei
formuliert hat ob es in der Ukraine
wirklich ein russischer Einmarsch sei
oder nicht doch ein innerer Bürgerkrieg
wie gehen sie mit solchen Positionen
künftig um so wir sind da diesem
Wochenende damit umgegangen wir haben
gesagt absolut inakzeptabel und wir
werden den Ältestenrat neu besetzen
damit ist das Thema für uns klar und
eindeutig geklärt aber ich will noch mal
kurz zu dem Punkt den die Kollegin
Büning angesprochen hat und zwar wenn es
darum geht dass wir über die erhöhte
Rente reden dann ist das ja das was die
Rentnerinnen und Rentner eingezahlt
haben das ist ja kein besonderes
Geschenk der Bundesregierung mal aus
besonderen Gründen sondern es ist ein
schlichtes schlichter
anwartschaftsanspruch und aber eins fand
ich interessant dass der Kollege Czaja
sagt naja wir wollen da
verantwortungsvoll mit dem Bundeskanzler
zusammenarbeiten das heißt der faktisch
es gibt in diesem in dieser Frage
nämlich das Sondervermögens faktisch
eine große Koalition und ich frage mich
warum gibt es eigentlich wir sind für
uns Sondervermögen ich will dass du
deutlich sagen aber für ein
Sondervermögen für die Energiewende von
100 Milliarden und ich frage mich warum
wir nicht dafür das Geld anwenden dann
müsste auch der Wirtschaftsminister
Habeck nicht nach Katar fahren um dort
die Gas Zusammenarbeit zu stärken
sondern dann Papier zügig die
Energieunabhängigkeit herstellen das ist
aus unserer Sicht viel wirksame und
nachhaltiger als das was derzeit
passiert nämlich eine sinnlose
Hochrüstung haben wir ja ich würde gerne
noch einen weiteren Aspekt Einbringen
der russische Angriff auf die Ukraine
macht hier erneuerbare Energien noch
dringlicher Bayern hat sich da beim
Ausbau an von Windkrafträdern ja bisher
merklich zurückgehalten werden sie das
verändern müssen lieber Herr Kolb Bayern
ist erneuerbare Energien Land Nummer
eins wir sind von Bundesländern Nummer
eins bei der Photovoltaik Nummer eins
bei der Geothermie Nummer eins bei der
Biomasse und Nummer eins bei der
Wasserkraft bei der Windkraft sind wir
auf Platz 8 also auch nicht auf Platz 16
sondern auf Platz 8 trotzdem ist Bayern
das eins Bayern ist das erneuerbare
Energien Land Nummer einserkühner das
müssen uns einfach nur mal zur Kenntnis
nehmen
wir wollen auch noch mehr Wind machen
mehr Windkrafträder in Bayern bauen und
zwar 500 plus X das ist die das erklärte
Ziel des Ministerpräsidenten ist es sehr
ehrgeizig wird diese Regel aufgehoben
der Distanz die zehn haarregelung die
10h-regelung hat aus meiner Sicht sehr
stark befriedene Wirkung vor Ort und sie
ermöglicht auch eine sehr starke
Bürgerbeteiligung sie ist nämlich
disponibel und vor dem Hintergrund wird
im privat beim Privatwald mit Sicherheit
die 10 haarregelung weiter bestehen bei
Staatswald gibt es sehr wohl die
Möglichkeit dass man auch von dieser
10h-regelung im Einzelfall Abstand nimmt
also sie werden eines sehen auch bei der
Windkraft wird Bayern zulegen wie gesagt
wir liegen da derzeit im Mittelfeld das
liegt aber nun mal auch das ist so
gegeben an der an der topografischen
Lage Bayerns wie gesagt bei allen
anderen vier erneuerbaren Energien
Formen sind wir Nummer eins also man
kann uns wirklich beileibe nicht den
Vorwurf werfen wir werden hier
rückständig im Bereich des Ausbaus
erneuerbare Energien ganz im Gegenteil
keine Staatsregierung keine
Landesregierung tut so viel wie die
bayerische
freiheitsenergien vielen Dank ja vorhin
ist ja der Krieg in der Ukraine
angesprochen worden und in hat das ist
eine enorme Veränderung
nicht nur für unser Land übrigens für
die gesamte für ganz Europa und für die
gesamte Welt das heißt wir werden nicht
nur in der Auslosung Sicherheitspolitik
neu denken müssen sondern dazu gehört
natürlich auch die Energiepolitik und
meine Botschaft sagt freiheitsenergie
absolut ist auch völlig richtig ich will
nur sagen die deutsche Energiewende so
wie wir die Energiewende politisch ja
auch in Deutschland formuliert haben sie
war ohne Corona und ohne also ohne die
pandemische Situation und ohne den Krieg
in der Ukraine schon eine enorme
Herausforderung das heißt die
Herausforderung werden jetzt noch größer
werden als bisher und da gibt es nach
wie vor viele Fragen die geklärt werden
oder müssen beispielsweise Ausstiege aus
der Braunkohle
und die klassische Frage zum Beispiel
jetzt weil sie auch die katharreise des
Wirtschaftsministers angesprochen haben
die die Frage wie schnell man es
schaffen wird von Gas aus Russland
unabhängig zu werden und das sind so wir
haben die werden uns jetzt beschäftigen
und ein letzter Gedanke wenn ich darf
gerade zum Thema Sondervermögen da ist
es mir unheimlich wichtig dass Regierung
und größte Opposition zusammenarbeiten
denn dies die Zeiten haben sich enorm
verändert wichtig ist dass demokratisch
und das sind dann Bundesaufgaben
losgelöst von der saarlandwahl oder von
anderen Landtagswahl ich danke Ihnen
hier in die Runde das war die Berliner
Runde zur Landtagswahl im Saarland und
damit geben wir zurück ins Wahlstudio
und zu Bettina Schausten
ja ganz herzlichen Dank Theo danke an
die Runde wir melden uns hier noch
einmal zurück im ZDF Wahlstudio denn
noch ist die Saarland Wahl nicht zu Ende
es tut sich auch immer noch etwas und
deshalb lohnt noch mal einen Blick auf
eine frische Hochrechnung mit Matthias
Horner so ist es wird noch weiter
ausgezählt aber wir kommen dem
Endergebnis immer ein Stückchen näher
und schauen in die nächste Hochrechnung
rein demnach hat die CDU 28,3 Prozent
die SPD 43,6 deutlich stärkste Partei
Die Linke nicht mehr im Landtag 2,5 die
AFD 5,6 wäre drin die grüne 5 die Grünen
5,0 ganz knapp die FDP 4,9 ebenfalls
ganz knapp und 10,1 Prozent 12 kleinere
Parteien sind da drin mit jeweils
weniger als zwei Prozent jetzt schauen
wir auf die Gewinne und Verluste was ich
ja bei so viel Bewegung lohnt die CDU
hier im Saarland verliert mehr als 12
Punkte die SPD gewinnt 14 die Linke
verliert mehr als zehn die AFD
verliert etwas die Grünen gewinnen dazu
einen Punkt plus 1,0 die FDP gewinnt
auch dazu und die anderen auch in der
Summe diese Verteilung im Saarbrücker
Landtag absolute Mehrheit bei 26 sitzen
die CDU käme demnach auf 18 Sitze die
SPD auf 27 AFD 3 grüne 3 und jetzt
schauen wir darauf was das heißt fürs
Regieren im Saarland wer kann mit wem
regieren zwei Szenarien entweder die FDP
ist unter fünf Prozent wo wir sie
derzeit sehen dann hätte die SPD recht
klar eine absolute Mehrheit mit 27
sitzen 26 braucht man kommt die FDP über
die fünf Prozent in den Landtag dann
wird es knapp für die absolute Mehrheit
sie hätte sie immer noch aber exakt mit
den 26 Stimmen die man braucht große
Koalition würde natürlich gehen Rot-Grün
würde auch gehen und ein soziale
liberales Bündnis wenn die FDP dann drin
ist auch das hätte eine deutliche
Mehrheit ja danke schön Matthias immer
noch das also die aktuellen Zahlen und
wir sehen schon bei den kleinen Parteien
tut sich noch etwas die Grünen gehen
jetzt wo die Briefwahl ausgezählt wird
etwas runter bei der FDP ist es noch
nicht ganz klar wir sehen Sie unter den
fünf Prozent klare Verhältnisse
allerdings an der Spitze ein Triumph für
die SPD an diesem Abend zweistellige
ruheverluste und zweistellige hohe
Gewinne und zweistellige hohe Verluste
für die CDU jetzt hören wir in beide
Parteien noch mal rein und beginnen mit
der Siegerin Anke Rehlinger die ihren
Erfolg so beurteilt
es bleibt bei dem was ich gesagt habe zu
Regierungsbildung
das wichtigste Kriterium ist Stabilität
wir werden heute erst irgendwann im
Laufe des Abends vielleicht erst in der
Nacht erfahren welche Konstellationen
möglich sein werden wichtig ist
Stabilität an dieser Stelle denn die
Aufgaben die vor uns liegen sie sind
schwer genug und deshalb brauchen wir
eine verlässliche Regierung die ist im
Zweifelsfall nicht nur Ergebnis einer
mathematischen Aufgabe sondern sie hat
auch etwas mit Vertrauen zu handelnden
Personen und zu Konstellationen zu tun
das habe ich den Saarländerinnen und
Saarländern versprochen alles dafür zu
tun eine stabile Regierung aufzustellen
das gilt auch auf der Grundlage dieses
Wahlergebnisses
ja und es sieht nach der absoluten
Mehrheit aus dann würde Anke Rehlinger
im Saarland künftig als neue
Ministerpräsidentin allein regieren so
der bisherige Ministerpräsident Tobias
Hans von der CDU hat seine Niederlage
und umbunden eingestanden und auch
Konsequenzen angekündigt Behörden auch
ihn noch mal
ich übernehme die Verantwortung für
dieses Wahlergebnis denn das
Wahlergebnis ist mit meiner Person
verbunden als Spitzenkandidat
und deswegen werde ich auch persönliche
Konsequenzen mit dem Vorstand mit der
Fraktion am morgigen Tag beraten und ich
bin sicher wir werden gemeinsam so wie
wir als CDU sah immer gekämpft haben
auch in diesen schweren Stunden dieser
Zäsur der Machtverlust nach 22,5 Jahren
gemeinsam gute Lösungen finden damit wir
im Sinne unserer Partei und auch im
Sinne dieses Saarlandes das eine starke
CDU braucht egal in welcher Rolle auch
wieder nach vorne blicken können
Tobias Hans der Wahl Verlierer so und
kurz vor Beginn des sonntagabend-films
wollen wir das ganze noch mal ein
bisschen bilanzieren und tun das ja
gerne mit Professor Karl Rudolf Korte so
wir haben auch die Berliner Runde
natürlich gesehen wenn man mal bei der
CDU bleiben also da war schon das
Bemühen sehr stark das fernzuhalten von
der Bundespartei und dem neuen
Bundesvorsitzenden Friedrich Merz ja so
eine Brandmauer gebaut worden verstärkt
worden geradezu und hat nur die Hand
gereicht der Regierung bei der
Fragestellung wie man Sondervermögen
mitfinanziert ansonsten ist die Berliner
Republik der CDU im Selbstgespräch dann
schauen wir mal auf das Ergebnis der SPD
das ist ein Triumph ein Kantersieg ja
geradezu Onkel rillinger hatte es vor
fünf Jahren schon mal versucht damals
gegen Annegret Kramp-Karrenbauer konnte
sie sich nicht durchsetzen weil das
jetzt die Stunde der künftigen
Landesmutter dieses Typus auch
vielleicht Rehlinger Bonus auf jeden
Fall damals gedemütigt aber jetzt als
Macherin ganz offensichtlich außer
alltäglich die vermutlich nicht nur 8
Regierung die die SPD stellt sondern in
dem bunten Reigen verschiedener
Regierungen die einzige absolute
vermutlich insofern etwas
Außergewöhnliches aus einer
Regierungsverantwortung heraus so etwas
hinzubekommen aber der Typus das machens
das sind entscheidend es geht um
Zukunftssicherheit verlässlicher
Autorität mit dem Blick auf den
kriegsabgrund hat das offenbar die
Wähler bewirkt bewegt so zu agieren ganz
stark die großen ganz schwach die
kleinen die Linke hier sozusagen
gescheitert wirklich krachend
gescheitert bei Grünen und FDP ist es
noch nicht ganz klar warum ist das hier
so ein schwieriges Pflaster im Saarland
für die Kleinen das ist selbst
verursacht das hängt nicht nur mit der
Stärke von Hans Rehlinger in der
Auseinandersetzung zusammen sondern
selbst verursacht selbstverzwergung
durch querel und Tier kennt jeder jeden
dabei spielt die Parteifarbe weniger
eine Rolle als die Kenntnis dass die
sich nicht einig und das wird dann heute
so auch abgerechnet letzte Frage jetzt
fragen sich alle wie ist es mit der
Signalwirkung für die nächsten Wahlen
das war das der Auftakt in das Wahljahr
22 Schleswig-Holstein NRW steht an und
auch dort stehen
CDU-Ministerpräsidenten zur Wahl wird
das jetzt in Durchmarsch der durchmar
spezifisch auf das Thema
Zukunftssicherheit in Kriegszeiten zu
agieren und auf den Typus nicht nur
etwas anzukündigen so etwas zu machen
wer das hat wird auch gewinnen Professor
karldorf Karte vielen Dank für die
Analyse und damit verabschieden wir uns
aus dem ZDF Wahlstudio jedenfalls für
diese Wahlsendung Matthias vorndorf
bleibt natürlich parat mit allen Zahlen
für das heute journal dass ich Ihnen
sehr empfehle und natürlich jederzeit
ZDF heute bringt sie auf den letzten
Stand jetzt das herzkino das haben wir
uns alle verdient also einen schönen
Abend tschüss
[Musik]